foreign
foreign
which I service expected but I didn't
really know what to do against
because in reality very few people do
when we are playing an even game against
someone of similar strength to us
usually we need to give something in
order to obtain the initiative just how
shrewd
cunning alireza can be even with very
little time I want to show you again
just to prove that I play these lines I
played against former world number two
and Superstar gattacamski
[Music]
welcome everybody my name is
Champion our starting a new course here
for Chester ball a very special chessful
course master your chest with Judith
Bulger you know what I learned a lot
foreign
[Music]
you are following my games you will see
I play a lot of games
finally guys so much work for just one
Pawn it's so much happiness
foreign
[Music]
plays a few good amounts stops looking
inwards into his own insecurities I like
the no expectation part so like that's
something that has gotten better because
sure it's like not my full-time job it's
definitely good purchase in India and
now there is Olympiad also so there will
be more people following and speaking of
Chess as professional sport yeah
and it's surprisingly concrete still no
like yeah it takes D4 good move because
if you take before the D takes E5 this
line was essential and forced but also
not the rocket science to map out
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to take control of your journey towards
chess Mastery Magnus Carlson introduces
chessable the definitive solution for
studying chess move trainer uses the
science of spaced repetition to identify
your strengths and eliminate your
weaknesses there's no need to set up a
board remember which page you're on or
keep track of all the moves you miss
move trainer empowers you to go from the
opening to the end game with confidence
it's seamless effective and fun way to
study chess choose from one of the
largest online chess libraries in the
world with hundreds of titles ranging
from classic books through to our
exclusive chessable courses including
over 100 free courses get expert
insights from International Master John
Bartholomew Grand Master Sam shackland
International Master Christoph selecki
Grand Master Simon Williams world
champion Magnus Carlson and hundreds of
other instructors get started now and
join our growing community of over one
hundred thousand chess enthusiasts at
chessable.com
accessible take control of your journey
towards chess Mastery the definitive
solution for studying chess choose from
one of the largest online chess
libraries in the world with hundreds of
titles ranging from classic books
through to our exclusive chessable
courses
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
remember
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
the fire is strong but I don't care
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to round six of the
that is still 2023 Vikings tournament
I'm Peter swindler and with me is uh my
good friend David Howell
days are full of
everything uh and and long but they are
very very exciting and we expect the
same today
yeah
oh sorry my sound cut out there yes
you're right Peter the days are very
very long indeed uh but it's been
non-stop action no boring games no quick
draws almost and
I've been loving
analyzing all of these these fascinating
study like end games these kind of
dramatic attacks that we seem to see day
in day out at this point and yeah I
can't say at some point it feels like it
will dry up but we haven't been
disappointed not so far no and yeah I
wanted to say occasionally in the course
of the same game actually because uh
that game uh clearly the game of the day
and arguably maybe even the game of the
tournament so far that noribbeck won
against Magnus yesterday it began as a
kind of a swashbuckling
attempt by Magnus to to shake things up
he sacrificed in exchange by move 15 and
uh it ended being a very very nicely
played very kind of a dry technical
Queen ending uh which was won by uh
noribbeck in a fashion
I think Magnus himself would have been
very satisfied with converting their
position this cleanly
in this straightforwardly uh very
impressive stuff by the uh bosbeck
youngster who is not leading the
tournament outright on as you can see on
your screen on plus three four out of
five
who started really well and uh who
inflicted the first of the two losses in
a row on Magnus in round four
is half a point behind and then there is
a group of people on
uh three out of five so obviously a very
long term and still eight rounds to go
plenty two
uh plenty opportunities for for everyone
to shake things up in terms of the
standings but the content has been
exciting and and
I've I've always loved watching bike
this year in particular I think we're
getting a very very good tournament
yeah they seem to have invited the
perfect uh blend perfect mix of
youngsters and slightly more experienced
players and uh yeah I guess the big
storyline of the day Peter will be
Magnus can he bounce back can he stop
the rot
don't think I ever remember him losing
three games in a row or Castle in Queen
side as they say yeah what's your record
my records I think three is I've done
three a few times those are those are
new numbers David
those are those are absolutely amateur
numbers you have to you have to pump
them up yeah I've done four twice twice
in my life okay
I would not I would not recommend it
yeah one is one is enough one is more
than uh yeah honestly yeah I think
General people do feel one is enough but
yeah four is
like a genuinely unpleasant feeling
yeah and uh they came in very different
circumstances as well my first ever I
don't know if I've ever if I've ever
actually done three it seems like if I
do three I do four uh my first ever was
Linares 99
where I actually began quite well and I
was kind of full of hopes for the
tournament in general I thought you know
this might be you know the year I do
something in in linaris I came and I
think I think I was on plus one after
round four
and then I lost
to in some order Vichy
Hungarian Vlad okay so decent which yeah
which can happen yeah definitely any one
of them separately can happen but even
even for in a row you can sort of
Imagine
but I also lost four in a row three of
them with white in a European Club Cup
in 20 I want to say 18. and that one was
kind of less explicable
because I think I was at least 100
points above everyone I was playing and
maybe more and I just kept on losing
games and it was just very odd was that
idea that your team your team won the
cup anyway yeah and yeah they won
basically they just gave everybody a one
board handicap and and one very
convincingly anyway and you nearly took
down Magnus in the last round I remember
that I was sitting next to it yeah yeah
you beat us guys yeah I I
decided to continue sort of blocking the
board and even had some winning chances
somewhere along the way uh okay so where
do we go the Game of Thrones I assumed
would have been uh
uh would have been the not a bad game uh
against Prague because this is I think
on points uh this pairing has the most
points of any pair in the round
but uh there's plenty of other very
exciting potentially very exciting
action Magnus is playing Black against
Jordan uh and uh you know as potential
bounce back games go
uh you would like to have the white
pieces
but black against Jordan I think is
sort of okay because I don't think
Jordan will be trying to I think he's a
kind of a guy to try and play kind of a
dry boring game try to minimize risk I
think Jordan will go for it uh I think
they have
very healthy sort of mutual Mutual
mutual respect and also uh they've
worked together in the past obviously so
um those do tend to be quite interesting
and uh Magnus has played the Sicilian
against Jordan there yeah uh Bishop B2
is not the most exciting reply to Queen
C7 which is kind of slightly giving the
light to what I was saying earlier but
we'll see even this could become quite
quite interesting yeah Jordan uh Jordan
hasn't had the best time himself so far
losing yesterday for fashion
um yeah you were going to say anything
catching the eye yeah like what's your
what's your pick because we have to uh
maybe Gary Eric I see a lot of the games
are very theoretical still
um
is there a queen text D4 Sicilian a bit
lower down
um that one looks like it could heat up
but still early days in all of the games
this one is still a Mainline position of
course
yeah Jordan does something very
interesting here though I assume the
point is as is always the case I think
these days some sort of windy 3g3
immediately trying to use the fact that
they've been on a C7
is surprisingly a bit vulnerable to
these type of types of things because
let's say you play G5 here you get the
immediately method Queen G3
and your choices are sort of annoying
because these end games have been I
think shown
not to be very easily equalizable they
G4 G5 is very simply quite a quite a
strong plan opening up The Rook on H1 is
generally quite nice for white
yeah and black does have the bishop on
C8 which is quite difficult to include
in the game and if you have to make a
second move with the queen on C7 you're
also not entirely happy obviously you
don't know which other Square you
uh even like very much in these types of
positions yeah um Martin is actually
pausing here maybe he is considering
taking with the queen which wouldn't be
outrageous lines like Queen takes and
then B5 Bishop B7 Rook C8 they have
existed in all of this balsans for
forever basically it's definitely
something you could consider doing yeah
the queen I guess is a bit of a Target
on C6 but
um yeah like you say it's a similar
lines as far as we know yeah um yeah
other openings that as usual there's
always an Italian there's always yeah
there's always somewhere in Italian
somewhere and so it's a slower Spanish
as
we continue remarking on this because it
is somewhat unusual and he was arguably
maybe the last of the you know truly
great players of the Modern Age
who was a bit of a you know one
uh one uh first move uh like solely
playing it's not entirely true I think
it would be fair to say that he wasn't a
one E4 player he definitely played both
G4 and C4 but he was very much uh
playing the closed openings and uh uh
this tournament I think every single
white game he's had he opened with one
E4
uh which is
uh I mean it's clearly has something to
do with the match
but there are two ways of explaining it
and both are valid and we don't know
which one it is it's possible that he is
preparing to actually do this in the
match as well
or he is just sending up this massive
Flair for team nippo uh giving them you
know an additional source of major
headaches yeah I have a feeling it's the
latter Peter I mean I don't think he's
necessarily caring about showing that
he's more than a one-trick pony but
yeah I also can't see him switching to
184 I mean he's got to world number two
with a certain repertoire certain kind
of approach it feels kind of too radical
to uh to suddenly go away from
everything you know everything you've
you're used to in the biggest match of
your life
yeah I would be shocked I've got to say
if if come April he's starting to play
one E4 because there's so many Sicilians
where he has minimal experience from the
white side that nepo could go to
and uh okay a whole bunch of other other
stuff of course yeah I don't think it's
entirely unreasonable but I I don't
think he needs to uh as well because I
think you know considering the things
that are going to be uh the likely reply
to both D4 and E4 uh when we talk about
uh Jan's opening repertoire
um I don't see why 184 will suddenly you
know feel a lot more attractive than
what he's been doing uh his entire life
because yes as you say absolutely
correctly there are plenty of Sicilians
that Jan could you know kind of say me
Bluff Jan has been
until very very recently a very solid
very exciting neither player for
instance and picking up neither of
as you're kind of a you know first first
four into one E4 you have to play Knight
off against sniper for three weeks is
maybe not you want uh but there's also
just simply the better of which appears
to be the main uh the main weapon of
uh of Jan uh Jans in recent years and
like switching from what you've been
doing successfully all your life to bang
your head specifically against the
petrol of wall
to my eyes does feel feel a bit strange
not every idea is uh not every other
player's idea of fun the Petrov
yeah uh and uh
an interesting point sort of in the
continuation of what we were saying yeah
people in chat are saying uh that it's
noticeable that he hasn't gotten either
of those things in this tournament yet
people just play like the the Italians
against him nobody tried asking him what
he means against the Battle of also
nobody played E4 C5 against him uh
I'm assuming he's just choosing very
carefully who to do this against Levon
is not a you know a major player of
anything but Italians and and real
opposers uh pragnananda is also I think
uh a fairly well established player of
those types of openings so I guess he
knows who he is doing this against but
still it's it's definitely a an
interesting topic to keep an eye on
maybe not so much for us but for for
team nepo for sure trying to kind of
glean some kind of a
uh an idea of why this is being done in
the meantime
uh Vincent kymer uh threatened uh Wesley
with a
with a marshall here
uh Wesley's thought for a bit and played
a four which is
I don't know if versions come and go
here do you feel that this is still the
main anti-martial these days
um I would say yes in general of course
there's others this H3 D3
um I still seem to see A4 every time uh
I barely see Mainline Marshalls right
now
uh at least over the last few months
yeah very very quickly it's all existing
this anymore yeah I mean A4 comes and
goes like you say but
still doesn't seem to be a consensus
what the black players are doing I think
there's lots of Trends there rugby
everyone was playing after the world
championship last year of course and uh
yeah there are others should be seven oh
yeah I think rugby eight in particular
but even Bishop B7 are uh
kind of uh magnus's uh magnuses so
purview if that's the word I'm looking
for because I
I think most people just play before
here and feel that those positions are
whether we are talking about d46 D5
which is a very direct line where you
generally have to know a little bit with
black but I don't think you're suffering
too much live on the show what to do
here yeah or the other option would be
this line d3d6a5 with I think these days
very much with the intention of snapping
on E6 and going 90-2 C3 in this type of
uh play
this sees a lot more action than Bishop
B7 and specifically Rook B8 which I
thought
uh was a very kind of an unusual uh heal
to well not die on because he's done
okay but to choose to even debate uh
uh by by Magnus because of the three
options
the only Advantage I see for a V8 is
that it's much less researched yeah
the idea right yeah much at least the
first time he played rugby just to catch
uh not most slightly off guard but I've
got to ask Wesley's played A5 and uh in
this position
I thought the idea was always to for
kind of force black to commit with D6
and then play A5 I don't know if there's
any difference at all I I think uh
well I would I would start with D3
myself and I agree with what you're
saying very much and but this is a kind
of a provocation which I think doesn't
quite work out for black I don't think
this is as good
as it as it might seem but yeah I also
just don't understand why you would give
that option
but
well alternatively like if you've looked
at this and you know that it doesn't
quite work you might as well like throw
a little bait out there and see for
instance you know becomes excited by
some Marshall type positions but in
general I think it's just a
transposition because I think black will
default to kind of normal things
regardless yeah in particular might uh
might refrain from playing D5 there
which doesn't feel in his style but Rook
B8 uh going off to the a pawn anytime
soon probably not yeah I don't think it
works very very well almost in in a a
like once D6 Bishop E6 Bishop takes C6
Fe happens then the idea of placing the
Rook on B5 and maybe even taking only
five in some position gains a lot of
strength but if you imagine trying to do
it here let's say I go D3 you go to B5
for instance something like this
could be unbelievably traumatic for
black because like I'm certainly not B3
and that Rook might that look
legitimately might never come home yes I
don't think it's coming home yeah it's
so immediately yeah you you do need to
prepare it I think Rook B8 is more a
kind of a hint that
you know time for you to play G3 sir
because if you play C3 I think here now
you will be quite happily and quite
readily going into the Marshall type
positions because the inclusion I think
of rugby 8 and C3 provides black with
uh plenty of additional sources of
counter play for instance like yeah I
haven't moved B6 here which might
already be creating some annoying
threats of
bc3 and ic3 and so on uh so I I assume
you go D3 here so what this does is that
it definitely locks white into a certain
way of playing perhaps the argument is
if you play D6 why it goes C3 and maybe
tries to put the pawn on D4 and not on
D3 at all okay interesting move order uh
potentially
yeah Vincent played repeat immediately
meaning he might have studied uh studied
this yeah
um I've got to say in the in the other
one of the other spanishers abdusator of
against Prague it's the open Spanish and
I'm not familiar it's a strange one yeah
I I actually wanted to discuss with with
this with you because I don't believe
I've seen this very much oh so they're
gonna say the same thing yeah they
played uh uh the old sort of the normal
open Spanish early in this tournament
Levon played Knight takes E5 here
against Prague
but did not really get very far in fact
I remember when I was commentating I you
know levon's magic and you know the
amount of games I played against him
they influenced me so much that uh
Prague equalized very very confidently
and very comfortably and I thought sort
of well done and then I went back to
take a look at it a bit later and I
realized
uh livonis maybe was kind of bluffing
and it it was I think possible for black
to play for more not that black had a
large Advantage but we I just it it
wasn't like I'm remarking about on this
just to just to say that
occasionally
even at this level I think reputation
actually plays a bit of a a bit of a
role because yeah you just assume that
somebody who is doing some weird stuff
in the opening or perhaps at that weird
spot where
opening transitions of the middle game
and uh uh a very very you know strong
well-established player just does sound
slightly offbeat or maybe even not
slightly but like seriously offbeat
things
and you find the quality and you think
aha I you know I defuse the very
dangerous idea instead of thinking this
looks strange might I not be better
already yeah yeah which maybe you would
have thought if it wasn't live on
exactly she definitely has an aura
around him of uh I mean he plays these
slightly weird ideas all the time so
when one of them is a bluff it's hard to
hard to spot but yeah Knight C5 and
taking a C5 that's extreme
Bishop three is uh
not the most fashionable move here but
definitely a move that has existed
forever Bishop B7 liability 295 all of
this is normal but yeah I don't think
I've ever seen a game between two strong
players which featured this particular
idea
just giving up the bishop bear straight
away
to do I'm not entirely sure what
unless the point is to attack D5 very
quickly but C3 takes the time out I
thought maybe the idea was quick for
kd-194
I think we pretty much always playing
Queen is seven right and then Rook 88
and once this is on the board
of life I think is very safely protected
yeah to say why you've given up the
bishop pair here maybe the another idea
could be just a quick Bishop C2 B4
Knight B3 and just
um
[Applause]
I like Queen E7 and pretty much every
single position here I think Bishop C2
probably does happen uh just to Chris
what you just said there I I didn't
really consider it properly but it might
be a
uh a thing to I don't know if you worry
about is the right term but at least
keep in mind I also wonder we'll just
not be true on it so maybe without beef
or beef was kind of a risky inclusion I
wanna
I'm sitting here wondering if it's
already a time for me for some reason to
include a move like G7 G6 which normally
you wouldn't really be making in
positions like this but now that there
is no dark Square Bishop on the board I
think I actually much prefer G6 to H6 uh
because I want to limit the diagonal for
this bishop I want to make sure that I
don't blunder uh
any tactics along this uh uh this
diagonal
addict Peter that you're creating a home
for the bishop G7 no and there's also a
specific reason why I'm doing that and
that reason is let's say you go before
Bishop b69 B3 I thought I might want to
play G5 G4 here
and I have sort of protected against
Queen E4 in advance because if I if I
play let's say Rook 88 before Mission
b69 B3 I would very much like to play G4
here yeah but it loses a piece actually
it doesn't
Queen F6 is I don't know guys yes so I
hmm
yeah also it's useful that for example
if black wants to play Bishop G4 and
variations that uh there's no way to
break them in
yeah I I like I don't know if it's time
already I think maybe we have more
useful things to do but I think g76 is a
like a genuinely useful resource here
just to make sure that
uh this is an an emptier piece than it
is currently and also just to make sure
we're not running into
um any tactics 27 on the board in the
meantime uh not a bit unsurprisingly
because you never ever do this without
prep like the movement like Bishop takes
C5
I think generally would not have
occurred to him if he hadn't looked at
this position at home so he is still
playing
very quickly uh Prague also reacting uh
quite quickly he did not take very much
time at all to Castle but that is
understandable you are always castling
here so first things first but even last
53 Queen E7 came very natural it is a
very very normal move here you have to
say
uh black doesn't have too many logical
options maybe you could aim for A4 in
some positions but it doesn't seem to
help uh A4 just B4 and don't really know
what you've gained that's why yeah so it
makes sense to kind of rearrange the
minor pieces
sooner rather than later
and yeah we'll wait to see the idea but
it's far from obvious
I'm really skeptical just too attached
to the bishop area yeah so am I I I'm
very much on the record of somebody who
really disliked the idea of parting with
the bishop bear in the meantime our
other our other Spanish has proceeded in
a way that we didn't really maybe expect
all that much if I was met by rugby
eight and here I think Wesley
demonstrates another reason for not
playing G3 or C3 and goes D4
a major difference with the lines we're
discussing earlier is that after G6 you
can at least consider playing D5 because
now Knight A5 is not a square you have
to go to A7 it's not the end of the
world but you can definitely consider
just going D5 and then developing
normally and claiming that
we have good control uh instead Winston
goes Knight takes D4 I guess
with the Rook on B8 this doesn't work
right because uh once again uh this is a
bit of an uh Advanced topic but if we
talk about anti-martials
there is the move G4 here
to which people can and maybe even
should just reply D6 because that pretty
much locks white into playing uh c3d4
which for years and years has a
reputation of not really giving much
more white very much but there is also
the movement that takes D4
against which white has the option of
doing what Wesley is doing
or there is the option of flame 7 and
95.
yeah and in this position because the
Rook is on A8 a kind of a natural
looking move like Knight E6 just
straight up loses material immediately
because white takes on a 7 goes e45 and
if the light goes somewhere you have
actually
lost the full Rook when I ate
but with the inclusion of uh a4v4 A500
B8 I guess if you try doing the same
there is nothing hanging on A8 so in
this position your attack just Fizzles
and you've lost material
yeah it does look very sharp still F4
and go for it but yeah I think you're
right uh with best defense that should
be solid enough
um yeah so instead we've got an equally
weird position which Vincent seems to
have prepared as well I'm very impressed
I've got to say uh Queen takes D4 B5
yeah rugby five in particular blitzed
out by Winston uh
um
is
yeah this is very peculiar to my I guess
he actually is threatening C5 rupay five
right yeah otherwise it's slightly
mysterious
if not what would be what would be a
reply to Bishop C4 simply and go back
but specifically here if he forced me to
uh take the pawn I think it's
viable
yeah where does you know I didn't really
see where the White Queen goes actually
say five looks like a healthy Pawn it's
quite nice having the opponent before as
well just stopping away from getting the
Knight to c3d5 very quickly
absolutely um
still a kind of a risky approach because
you will be investing a lot of time into
getting those moves in so let's say if I
go on that bg2 here are we still going
after the pawn
do we rush it's not going away unless
you put the knights on C4 potentially
next move
okay let's for argument's sake say I
take uh this Pawn on A5 uh I haven't
really chosen the square yet I was
looking at D3 or perhaps F4 but I think
F4 maybe belongs to the bishop uh so you
let's say you do this you know I go say
Knight C4
I assume in
let's not give it for B5 back perhaps A5
A4 to come yeah
yeah it's a it's a kind of a strange
position because
my original reaction and the reason I
was going to discuss this with you was
uh you know I I was going to say this is
just one Pawn
white has sort of vastly superior pieces
this is not doing very much this is not
doing very much and if it goes to C7 96
probably gains in strength in a lot of
positions broken f8 is locked in none of
these pieces really have any good
squares
and then I realized UAE 584 idea is
actually very annoying and also
maybe even the bigger issue is that I am
not sure
what threat I'm supposed to create here
you know what you attack and how you can
attack H7 in some variations I'll just
play G6 not G7 worst comes to the worst
does take a long time yeah I still don't
really feel like white should be worse
here but I'm sitting here staring at
this and thinking yeah like which before
doesn't do very much Queen G3 which I
thought might be a good idea
it's a good square but Bush by six is
still not a threat and a5a4 is coming
you know perhaps Bishop B7 Bishop D5 now
that the queen has
decamped from from D3
yeah it's it's just a very complicated
position uh do we have an option of not
giving up on A5
maybe we're committed because yeah C5 or
K5 happens no matter what I think it's
the same question it's like what do we
attack where do we put our pieces you
know weirdly it might like we actually
might have to play some kind of a
position like the one we're just
discussing because it doesn't really
it doesn't really feel
uh like we will be given much of a
choice because having played rugby 5
it's very difficult for me to imagine
black just leaving it there and not
actually making use of the threat you've
just created like if 92 should be seven
like you you might regret not ah this
this allows Rook D5 there
but for example we'll say queen C4 and
then maybe between sorry Bishop C4 Queen
G4
and uh D7 will be hanging in the end of
that line so
um
takes A5 okay you can take but you can
just flavor B1 maybe there and maybe
attract on A5
yeah yeah
uh we'll leave this here for a bit
because it's a very interesting position
and uh I think Wesley's next decision
will be
um
I still you know where this game goes
other positions uh ding's position
against Levon has
actually kind of defined itself quite a
bit by move 10 because uh here I think
every single Avenue was still possible
for both sides uh but after C3 uh live
on Play Bishop B6 which
uh I think it's originally modern
approach because uh in my childhood we
were taught that you are kind of
autopilaging H6 Play Seven everywhere
just to make sure this bishop is uh
away from potential trades
or the night and just kind of safe and
tucked away on A7 but she saves the
tempo compared yeah there's an argument
for A4 here for white uh just asking
black to play A6 eventually and then the
bishop it's on B6 rather than A7 in many
of these lines
at least like you yeah I was always
tired
I think the point is they go A5 and then
they go 97 96 and the bishop if white
actually generates the idea of 929 C4 I
think you will almost always be in time
to play six between December 67
um I don't think people play Bishop B6
with the intention of playing A4 A6
yeah because that would be quite weird
because white would get
I think
a version of what is now more or less a
main line of these uh
uh jacobinissimo uh variations between
the bishop 1 B7 B6 instead of A7 which I
assume is not an advantage yeah and this
is come back into fashion after players
discovered that you can even spend a
tempo as black on A6 and meeting A4
ideas with A5 later so yeah B6 actually
makes a lot of sense there
um yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't hate that
at all because yeah as you mentioned we
did manage a4a5 with black in one tempo
and I think Sasha Grisha was one of the
earliest people who started very very
seriously unironically so to speak I
started doing this and then keeping the
bishop on C5 yeah
um and yeah I remember when I saw this
for the first time I thought you know
this can't possibly be any good but must
be a joke yeah it must be must be some
kind of a mass sleep or whatever but
it's not
uh stopping white from Gaining too much
space on the queen side is definitely
something that you want uh anyway after
Bishop B6 I didn't play rookie one only
one continued with that same plan of 97
1960 65 and so on and then immediately
played D4
allowing uh this very forcing
continuation of text takes D5 which uh
gives white an isolani for
the rest of days
and a very interesting choice here by
livon
and still played very quickly so I'm
assuming this is not
uh ad-lib diver uh Levon spends a Tempo
on H6 here
very much indicating that he would not
have been very happy with some position
like
like this let's say the numbers B6 and
I'm not entirely sure how we're supposed
to do it Tempo by Tempo but I guess you
play like Queen B3 Knight C3 or
something like that
yeah it doesn't feel too scary the pin
you can always just play Queen D6 at
some point as well it's yeah it's
surprising to take the time out with H6
but okay perfectly understandable things
last move after H6 to play A4 here means
is he going for checkmate Peter or is he
gonna lift his Rook up via A3 I think uh
it's a kind of a it's it's a weird one
right because
considering the fact that we're very
much assuming there will be a Black
Knight on G5 and
a reasonably immediate future by playing
A4 like black will not blunder A5 and
just you know resign due to losing the
bishop on E6 so a very very likely
response is A5 here and then
you've given black an additional very
very safe Square to aim for them before
yeah this is uh horrendous for white but
I guess it softens up the bishop B6 a
little bit
in case you want to play it on ic395
Queen B3 straight away and also as you
have mentioned I don't know if like I
suspect black hasn't done enough wrong
to deserve getting mated here
immediately but something like 95 90d5
through K3 yeah weird as it may seem
uh
cool actually could actually be quite
scary yeah because like my problem with
this is some kind of move like Knight E7
might you know sort of stop Rook G3
forever because the Knight gets rerouted
to F5 but if you make one sort of a
autopilot you move here with black you
play which B6 we go rub G3
um
it's very very possible for this to be
extremely made adjacent like King h8 I'm
already kind of interested in Bishop H6
ghind it though yeah it might not work
might not work but I am very interested
yeah uh you know
specifically here I think you have Queen
F6 in the end so I I'm sort of one tempo
short from playing Bishop D3
forcing that to F6 and then playing
rookie through G3 made so maybe it's a
little bit too speculative for now
but it's very very adjacent too
positions where something like this
might just win
yeah I I played a match against Neil's
Cornelius last year and he did something
very similar to me he played A4 at a
moment where it looked like uh long term
it's just creating loads of weaknesses
in okay three Rook G3 came in lo and
behold I got mated to say yeah
um yeah interesting interesting position
uh the fact that he's thinking makes me
wonder whether he's about to play Bishop
A5 that's the only other yeah you don't
want to play A6 and get your Bishop
pushed back the whole way and it's the
only alternative I can come up with
uh well uh
a very live one way of reaction to this
would be to play C6 but I don't think it
works it's not even that ridiculous
because after dc96 you do have some
pressure against this Pawn on D4 if the
ball was back on H2
I have a feeling this might have been an
actual thing to consider semi-seriously
uh because afterwards P3 would have had
access to
the idea of Bishop G4 putting on further
pressure against this Pawn but with upon
H3 yeah it's difficult to imagine how
this works out yeah
yeah so Bishop A5 I guess we play Knight
C3 95
Maybe
Bishop D2 would be normal or queen B3
yeah I'm choosing between
yeah and I don't know C6 maybe yeah I
guess we're just arguing that
due to the sun pressure on C3 it's a bit
annoying for white to uh try and whip up
any attack
[Music]
Queen B3 sometimes you can meet with
Queen B6
it's interesting at least I I have no
idea I've got no idea whether it's
objectively correct or uh playable but
yeah it is it is just the fact that he's
thinking uh when it looks like A5 is so
automatic for black
yeah I think it's a very serious option
so he is choosing within those two
things uh there is a lot of excitement
in our chat uh regarding the game
between Geary and uh a guy see uh this
is a very very old school Maron
a sort of a classical meron which has
not disappeared exactly but has become I
think a lot rarer than all of the queen
c2s and the bishpitus of this world
um going for these very very
uh classical lines Asics is a choice in
this position of course and even in this
position you can choose to play before
straight away you can also choose to
play before here after castles but A6 is
a maybe the most kind of a bold School
way of playing the mirror and you are
preparing 65 and playing it against
anything
E4 C5
wife here has a choice between E5 and G5
E5 I think they have
sort of I think analyzed to
uh
conclusive good results for black at
least in my understanding so G5 is I
think the main move
C4 Bishop C2 Queen C7 and I get the
feeling that Queen E2 here is
a somewhat rare removed
then uh let's say G Fe and 95 yeah there
was some Kasparov game there right after
Knight G5 uh also you can take an E6 and
play E5 immediately if I remember and it
gets super Sharp but uh we need to I'm
sure this has been played it can't be uh
brand new and yeah yeah
very difficult to find Novelties number
13 of the very very
well-trodden merons yeah yeah is not
very popular among uh the the absolute
Elites and uh the the strongest players
who have played it have played it in the
90s like there's a game between karpov
and uh Miguel yeskas from 1995 and Boris
girlfriend played it a couple of times
in 92 once against team one and once
against the escas again
um he's been studying his Classics initi
scary
yeah I think
the way maybe to think about it is that
uh all these kids are extremely well
booked up on sort of the modern
approaches to all these openings but
using something that may have sort of
slightly slipped under the radar
is is going to be a good strategy
because it's impossible to cover
everything and equal depth yeah so you
make like if if you know this is
playable if you if you have some idea
specifically for one game off between
each two and I niche
seems like he maybe even expected
the Marana is one of the things that
could happen today
judging by the speed of play
it's hard to predict Arjun he plays
pretty much everything these days and he
knows everything very well but uh yeah
it definitely seems like Anish must have
looked at this quite recently I like the
fact that he's getting back down against
Magnus he kind of played at the most
ambitious uh kind of Main Line he's
going very ambitious again if you catch
shot with the game Castle's Queen side
is committal yeah is committal and the
engine doesn't like it the engine says
Bishop D6 here was stronger a move that
maybe looks a little bit scary because
you're sort of stepping into Forks but
uh you're controlling the E5 Square well
enough not to worry about losing 20 45s
here and
well very often black just wants to play
95 themselves in particular after this
trade if that trade happens yeah 94
sometimes comes in as well and just park
at night I remember those I I guess it's
not entirely unreasonable to at least
give yourself an option to pass link of
castling King's side yeah even if you
end up not using it so exactly when I
was trying to make this line work I was
looking at it once for black and I
remember trying to Castle kingside was
always on the uh kind of the priority
because of Queen side just looks so so
shaky yeah
the 595 all of this is played and
honestly this is one of those weird
positions where
of course you know we've all by by the
year uh the year 2023 we've learned
not to distrust the computer output
but
I think my initial reaction here with
black would be I'm doing really well
okay uh yes I understand my skin my king
is vulnerable but it's not that easy to
actually
challenge this structure if you play A4
I will have to I will have the option of
playing B5 before and it doesn't really
look like it's any kind of the end of
the world uh
and on the other hand the bishop B7 has
been very much strengthened
by the fact that white had to play 45.
it now has a full sort of long diagonal
to operate the other one might come out
to C5 the Knight might come out to see
fight and start tying the very very
tasty D3 Square
we have a weakness only six but
apart from the move Knight G5 it's very
difficult to figure out how it can ever
be attacked and if you do play Knight G5
we can for instance take take only five
I I'm not saying I'm better here with
black but I wouldn't really be worrying
too much about this end game either it
doesn't really look like an endgame
we're going to be in any kind of trouble
in
but the engine always has you know very
concrete ideas about these things
and uh currently as I understand it the
point is we can take take we can play
Four before
once again seems like this is just
making Black's life easier because it
should be people maybe no it just goes
It goes it includes Bishop G5 ah okay
and then it very specifically goes B3
wow okay yeah uh the point being that
with the bishop 25 and not B7 if you
play C3 you've lost the A6 Pawn with
check uh and it doesn't go C3 but once
again like for me as a complete
Philistine in these types of structures
I have to wonder if I play C3 here Queen
A6 Queen B7
how bad can this be
why am I supposed to even be worse here
with black
very good question maybe the computer
just takes the board and moves once I
mean I want to put the bishop on C5 I
want to play Rook hf8 and I want to
claim that I have a protected passer on
C3 tremendously strong Bishop on the
phone on G5 all these Bishop takes F3
ideas the E5 Pawn is vulnerable and I've
given up one Pawn for it I understand
I'm down some material but it's not like
I've given up three or anything so but
if I keep the Queens on maybe just yeah
with A5 A6
yeah this is this was also what I
finally decided must be the problem but
I mean this is unbelievably unclear to
my eyes like a 16.6 A7 King B7 I'll
pardon the King on A8 and thank you for
A7 Bond because it will be just covering
me against all the all the attacks for
the future
yeah and I am developing like I will
obviously Bishop takes F3 probably is
never playable because allowing before
is impossible but I will be threatening
Rook takes a friend yeah maybe after
work fd1 still it's hard for black too
yeah whip anything up okay here okay
maybe yeah you just put a knight on B6
and you can argue that you're still
super safe and once again I will restate
the obvious if the engine says this is
much better for white it probably is
much better for white I'm not going to
be arguing with the with the uh you know
ultimate brains of modern engines but
from a purely from a purely human
standpoint
a wide split here is also incredibly
committal you know you are going to have
to play very very uh energetically and
uh keep on asking questions otherwise I
think black very soon
could start even assuming control
uh in the meantime a couple games we
have not covered I mean not not at any
length uh Fabi has a kind of a quiet ish
position in
Oregon against kukesh so classical or
goes in by move four
uh and then probably went for
this line where
very trendy stuff yeah go cash used this
line himself if I remember as white
against sargassian in the Olympiad for
this E3 Queen C2
uh with success to win a nice game there
but uh yeah he would have analyzed
surprise okay there is uh still a few
more minutes I was gonna say I'm
surprised if gokash pause to think here
um but he played Knight E7 which is not
a move I would have expected in a kind
of a
think a bit of a concession you're not
really trying to equalize on the spot I
think if you play Knight D7 here uh but
also probably not cooked up at the board
probably something that he is
uh at least thought about
and now we have a position where
um if white is allowed to finish
development can sort of find challenged
just Bishop D3 Castle short I don't know
95 you're going to be
very pleasantly
uh surprised by the outcomes of the
opening I think with white so black
probably has to
start some counter play in the center
faster oven so sooner rather than later
how would you go about this here
it feels like you need to either plant a
knight on e4 or play with a quick C5
I'm not sure which one both yeah or both
yes or both I mean C5 always feels
double-edged you're opening White's uh
kind of uncontested dark Square Bishop
but if you're gonna do it ever then it
feels like now
yeah I don't think we're very worried
about uh why doubling our pawns on F6
because I think we'll have
plenty of counter play and white
generally never really has enough time
to exploit the weakening um
worried about uh
F6
[Music]
yeah something like this and then just
castles with crazy one recover G1
positions like this that they don't
really look like we've entirely
equalized we get started with Rook C8
which I think also gives a
kind of a
window into his thinking C5 is coming
the question is
uh exactly when and how it however
effective it will be
uh there's also a very weird very rapid
like Sicilian in the game between Robert
and Max Sudlow Peter I think maybe just
before we uh we delve into this game too
much I think we need to just take a very
short technical break sure and then
we'll dig deeper this as you say is
shaping up to be an exciting one so
we'll be back with everyone
[Music]
thank you
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back and apologies for this
short technical technical break which
was an actual technical break and not on
euphemism for anything else as our chat
briefly suspected there as Chad always
is liable to do uh yeah we were talking
about the kind of a weird very rapporty
rapper Game today very in progress where
Rickard you know fooled Parham for one
move here by playing Knight of three
maybe even put two moves in a row and
let's just see them by playing another
three and G4
and then nope
nope no classical Sicilians for you can
takes D4 and Knight F6
uh Knight C3 Knight C6 and even weirder
here because I've actually kind of
dabbled in in Bishop B5 I lost a very
one of the four games I mentioned
earlier in the show that I lost in the
Nars 99 was in this specific position
against Gary I for some reason I decided
that open Sicilian is not safe enough to
play against Gary whereas Queen takes D4
for some reason is uh spoiler alerted it
still wasn't very same uh yeah so but
Richard just goes Queen D3 here says uh
you know I don't care about your
uh you know
Luster's guides for amateurs over the
week like I don't know what the what the
exact English name of that book is but
like most books most books he will read
about you know opening principles will
tell you that multiple moves with the
queen early on in the opening are to be
avoided
uh yeah Richard says no no do not
believe that to be true Queen D3 the
concept is so trendy that he's willing
to take two moves yeah two moves to put
it there and G3 is not even available
yeah yeah it's very very curious uh g695
57 C3 this is a very useful inclusion
because without that move black at some
point will become very very interested
in 95 55 9 before it would become a
thing but you would have to calculate on
every single move
uh Parham Castle Bishop G5 Bishop B6
demonstrating sort of proving that
Knight takes F6 at least for now is not
a threat that black needs to address
Bishop of the funny two are in this
position by Richard
basically claiming that
like if I were to describe it
record is playing
a kind of a
Bishop E2 against uh
but
let me let me I think the easiest way
would be to put it on the board and come
back yeah because I think people have
done this I I've not really done this
very much myself with the white pieces
but sorry this is not the dragon uh but
it has been done against me via
different movado's I think for me
specifically it always came actually by
either if the Rouser move or like people
playing with people here
and then switching to to these types of
positions and Newcastle and in order to
get something like what we're watching
white has to make all of these modes
let's say Bishop B6 Bishop G5 would be a
as close a comparison as I can you know
weep up on very short notice so this
would be a position uh uh occurring from
either there's the Raza bishpitsu or the
Dragon bishpitsu
uh where White had to waste time on
playing with one because the uh simply
in order to play in ic3g5 you have to
protect the pawn on e4 and that
generally is being done by by rookie one
and black already has the pawns on a675
black
uh
generally I think in all these positions
the variation is quite favorable for
black you're not very worried as a
civilian Blair if people do this against
you uh Richard is doing a kind of a
version of that
where he will not have to waste any time
on rookie one in the future because the
pony 4 is already protected
A6 and B5 is not on the board yet
white is one move away from Gosling then
The Rook I guess goes to G1 no D1 at all
or maybe the other one goes to D1
and uh black still needs to sort of
declare what they're doing against all
of that
I I can tell Peter you're kind of
talking yourself into liking White's
position and uh you're right it's
actually it's hard to find a plan for
black in this exact I think I think it's
it's always pretty it starts with Knight
D7 because I I don't like to attempt why
tempt why too much with the idea of
taking on H on F6 for example with H6
yeah I think H6 is playable I I don't
think you can refute it outright but I
feel like the way to go about things
would be to play 97 and then try to play
H6 and if it goes to H4 I am playing 6g5
quite happily I think one thing that
worries me a little bit is perhaps this
move Queen E3 which I originally did not
notice
because uh it it kind of cleverly
sidesteps the Tempe with Knight E5 on
Knight C5 and also prevents H6
making all of our declared counter play
somewhat harder to
organize yeah I mean you mentioned
playing H6 in the current position and
uh White has the chance to wreck the
black pawn structure but I mentioned
this the other day it's one of my
favorite Pawn structures in chess this
uh
now the bug Health structure of double
death pawns you do have a super safe
King you get the bishop pair if white
takes this way maybe you could also take
the other way yeah
I'm not sure which one
um Bishop F4 I assume and the argument
here is black either has to
play Knight E5 and Vlog called maybe D5
also yeah occasionally maybe maybe you
can try playing for the F5 break as well
but then you are you're breaking your
beloved structure so I don't know how
true I guess the bishop wants you to
break it out the bish1 G7
it gets it gets very specific because I
think if you do nothing nothing with
black for like a few moves and white
gets to play I don't know castles Rook
have G1 put the queen on back on G2 and
Bishop on D3 too
I'll make the F5 push more difficult to
organize you will have at least some
Advantage but all of the structure
changes here that black has are somewhat
playable even
you know going back to your Cairo
uh structures even d65 which looks like
you're really driving the point home
that you're sort of upon down in every
single end game uh it turns out that
and once again these are just to show
structures I don't think these are
exactly the moves you need to be making
but this type of a structure these pawns
take away a lot of very useful squares
uh and uh they fight for the center a
lot better than it might look at first
glance I don't think this is horrible
the reason I am somewhat doubting my own
choices here is that after 51 maybe we
don't have a particular good square and
like Queen B5 then we'll win more than
before wide so maybe you can do it
smarter
yeah but all of this is playable so yeah
the options currently as I see them are
H6 97 maybe Queen A5 question mark
question mark
just to ask the question just to ask the
question I don't know if you know
provoking before is so smart
but before right now feels quite
listening just because it feels like the
white C3 Pawn is going to be a big
Target but yeah unfortunately a couple
of Rook D1 or yeah this is why I'm doing
calculating yeah well
because let's say if we wait for a move
if we include Rook C8 castles and we
play Queen A5 here why feel very happy
to play Rook 71 and we've achieved
precisely nothing yeah we asked a very
simple question and there was a very
simple answer available to White so we
have not provoked the night to go away
we have not provoked white to take one
F6 uh it Still Remains an option later
but for now white has not been pushed in
any direction
whereas if we play Queen A5 straight
away Rook D1 I assume I will quite
happily
just munch yeah I was wondering about
trying to trap you with like Queen B5
Bishop C4 but
um I doubt it somehow I blundered there
but I have the A5 square right so but
then this Knight takes E7 oh yeah that
is a good point yeah that is a
that is a very sound point I'm just
trying to justify giving up the a pawn
but it somehow feels superficial it
feels like you can play A6 at the right
time and I'm not sure now but
hmm
yeah it gets very weird yeah maybe I
couldn't even do this right and if
Bishop's C I have the choice between A5
and day six maybe A6 is slightly smarter
even yeah Queen A6 um yeah you have one
a very important point on e4 yeah in the
process because I I will have to give up
some Pawns in return probably the E7
opponents in some version but collecting
both A2 and D4 should give me yeah
uh should give me something uh it's also
a very very committal way to play for
white so other options would be taking
on F6 with whatever you choose to take
on a six with perhaps a slightly awkward
move like Knight F4 or Knight E3 which I
am not really a huge fan of like Knight
F4 we go to 57 and now H6 is very much
on the menu next move
this looks like legitimately awkward for
white and Knight E3 while
looking maybe slightly less awkward is
still you know giving us plenty of
ammunition with ideas of Knight E5
Knight C5 this is a vulnerable piece I'm
actually sort of talking myself into
before here weirdly because I really
dislike everything else before we have
to calculate if white wants to play safe
maybe just Bishop takes F6 maybe Knight
F4 Knight F4 here
this is an important resource yeah yeah
at least if you want to keep the bishop
Powers black then you'll have to
maybe London
okay Bishop G4 Castle I guess castles
and yeah I wanted to play a five and
claim that I'm fine I couldn't play a
five I don't know if the claim is
correct like my issue is I don't know if
I'm if I'm lying or not about being okay
but you might be fine I think I'm okay
and important bit here is that this
actually pretty much always loses the
queen well I mean doesn't lose the queen
but the only square is A3 yeah
you will not enjoy the resulting end
games
uh so you have to do something else you
have to play it on a queen you two or
queen D5
and the bishop there I think more or
less entirely ensures that black is not
worse in positions like this yeah I
agree Queen A5 yeah I'm starting to like
I've got to say
yeah I think it's very playable I I
think well
it has a lot to uh to recommend it
because it's uh very much commits
commits white to a decision yeah and
White's done some weird wonderful stuff
in the opening so it's only logical that
Black's kind of best reply would be
something slightly off offbeat and queen
A5 or H6 yeah
um okay in the meantime uh our chat
reports that 5B is on plus two against
good cash wow which is honestly kind of
stunning because
it looks nice for white I'm not gonna
lie I do like this for white but if I
were to like to venture and guess what
the evaluation here is like I would say
maybe like plus 070 or
uh what have you maybe there's a direct
way to win a pawn I was also going to
say Peter just uh earlier when we were
on this game if we go back a couple of
moves to B3 oh sorry no yeah this one
okay okay yeah sorry uh B3 just before
Rook C8 I was having flashbacks here and
it's because
um in the Olympiad uh gukesh had this
position as white against Abdul sotorov
in a very famous game except there was a
difference the pawns were on A5 and A4
so black support that's that's how it
started yeah he was winning by move 20
exactly as white and now he's playing
from the black side and it's slightly
different
um and therefore the game has changed
but he's going to be having flashbacks
as well normally if you
have a traumatic experience like he did
in that game then it really does affect
you and maybe that explains why he's
kind of rushed into this yeah
is just crushing
wow which I can sort of believe honestly
because like the the move that
the move that comes to mind is 98 and if
you have to play 98 here you're just not
going to like
uh your position
very much afterwards because even after
let's say Bishop B2 it's going to be so
difficult to move your pieces
because there is also Bishop before
constantly to be on the lookout for
yeah you're right Bishop B2 I was going
to say maybe you can be clever with C
takes D5 and try and win a pawn but I
don't think it quite works out uh yeah
that as well actually yeah Queen C7
ah this is saying yeah yeah so yeah
quite but just basically two as you say
and black is yeah I I think yeah I think
it's just a very very poor position
after Bishop because you like it's just
going to be very difficult to finish
development
ah and uh the
uh the the very strong players of our
chat are also saying that are now
something like this something like this
might might be
like legitimately very painful which
also looks like it's probably true very
unbelievable yeah do you think C7 being
a threat of such magnitude that
you're just losing material
yeah yeah
so quimby2 how easy is queen beat sir
the fact that he stopped and not played
bishop e2s or Bishop B4 as uh a bit of a
giveaway though
I mean now you say Quimby too it's like
super obvious but
um it is a it is a kind of uh forcing
move it's a threat
yeah I think the issue for fiber here
will be that
many things look at least playable
Bishop D3 certainly looks like it's a
very sensible playable move which I
honestly don't even know how black is
supposed to react to that it looks very
attractive to me because H7 is hanging
if we include Bishop d3h6 it feels like
we've achieved something with white
because we've developed one more piece
and
uh black is still not really doing very
much Knight G6
appears to just plunder full exchange
division before at least I couldn't find
any way why it isn't just a full-on
blunder over an exchange so I think 5B
might be slightly spoiled for Choice
here which is
uh
yeah surprisingly not very useful in
these types of positions yeah you just
want one good move and everything else
looks illogical or everything else fails
but uh Bishop D3 I do wonder how much of
a threat taking on F6 is for example
yeah maybe it is or maybe Quincy
yeah I suspect you have to already kind
of commit to something like that because
at least here you can calculate a bit as
black girlfriend in sequence C4
um we can meet Bishop B4 with Rook C7
and I think we survived
but uh yeah I mean this is just to to
try and get into inside fabi's mind
um
two two questions from from a question
and a statement the question is why is
white meaning of the Queen Victoria well
I assume you can I can just take twice
and just be quite happy about things
because you're still not really
threatening to take C4 I assume you play
I don't know the five or Knight G6
and let's say if you play 96 even very
very simply just go and cd5 which
perform Rook F1 you know you know we're
upon up we're also about to give you an
isolation D5 it looks like legitimately
looks winning doesn't look better it
looks winning for white yes um so yeah
black is in trouble and so that was the
question that was the the question there
was also a bit of info provided which uh
will sort of reintroduce our
our favorite segment on the show where I
asked David to name a computer line and
he does it in in one try the second best
move in this position let's go after
Queen BT yes
ageful
always do it in one try yeah basically
the moment the question is asked yeah
I think you you kind of it's It's I I
was actually reasonably certain in you I
I knew I could trust you with this thank
you Peter yeah
I mean
yeah but the fact that I'm asking the
question gives you gives enough of a hit
to a very strong player like yourself to
kind of know where where to look and
yeah like H4 with the idea I guess of
Simply 95 and going after it yeah
sometimes Rook H3 Rook G3 yeah G3 or H5
H6 even yeah it's just strong
it's strong in every single position
seemingly maybe not the starting
position although Magnus has
recently been
I caught a bit of his stream when he was
streaming the The Faculty the title yeah
and he was he was starting with H4
and uh it sort of exp and then playing a
normal game of chess like he would go
h45 G4 or something
and and just discussing the usefulness
of the move H4 in various structures and
like the game that I watched
like by move 12 H4 was incorporated
seamlessly into what he was trying to do
and in fact White had like a massive
attack on the king side already while
like seemingly just playing with black
with the inclusion of H7 H5 in some
random position so yeah it's a it's some
kind of weird black magic when when he
does it yeah but but computers have
shown this this may be an argument for
it in Practical terms there's always an
attack right yeah black can never play
on autopilot uh even starting with one
H4
um but yeah again this is the type of
move once we say it it's kind of obvious
there's such clear logic but uh yeah so
hard to
keep naming it until then let's put it
like this we weren't actually glamoring
for white to play H4 until until it was
mentioned to to me and twitch chat yeah
which one of the two which one of the
two seemingly strongest movies easier to
make I think Queen B2 is probably
easier to settle on without computer
assistance because there the logic is
much more mundane we you know we attack
porn we force black to make very awkward
Looking Backward moves we like all of
those things
kind of very very cave Manila logic you
know yeah once you see that the Black
Knight can't move on E7 because the
bishop before then you start looking for
these things
yeah I'm I'm assuming fably will spot it
third play though if he plays H4 that'll
be super impressive yeah that would be
that would be pretty good in the
meantime uh uh there's a lot of
development elsewhere I don't even know
where to go let's briefly visit Magnus
and just talk about this for a bit it's
maybe the easiest to discuss because
there will not be very many forcing
lines yeah Magnus did take on six with a
queen white played Bishop E3 Bishop F3
which is quite logical Bishop B7
and here Jordan made the move Queen D4
which is honestly quite topical in these
types of positions because if you if you
speak about plans that black has here
the movies preface C5
is
often at very near the top of things you
want to do because you just generally it
needs to be developed somewhere
and the bishop 23 is quite useful
whereas the bishop and F3 if you're left
with the bishop on F3 versus the bishop
on B7 I think you actually pick the
bishop on B7 as the more useful piece
it has a bit more kind of relevance to
the fall to the Future play
uh and queen D4 stops that
also uh makes it harder for black
generally to do things in some cases
prepares long castles it's a kind of a
nice all-purpose move
I think the autopilot reply here is Rook
C8
to have the option of meeting if I could
be blown castles with before even though
variation actually continues you you
have to
uh you have to be sure you're doing well
here and maybe you're not because by
luring the queen away from the C file we
we do get to play Knight E4 and these
types of positions could just be
straight up lost for black it's not
impossible for this to just be extremely
bad
uh and mom was after some thought
came up with the move Queen D6
which will successfully take the Queens
off the board
while also costing him quite a bit of
time
it's reminiscent of this famous Berlin
draw this queen of D4 Queen on D6 yeah
but Taylor why can't Dodge yeah here
here there are no squares for you for
you to dodge so I assume having gotten
here you just castle and take the bishop
and play this position but once again
like
this is not great yeah Jordan wouldn't
be happy somehow he's not gonna ever get
any kind of uh ambitious kind of
attacking uh type of position yeah
especially against Magnus yeah I've got
to say I'm surprised Peter he didn't
play Queen D3 instead of Queen D4
knowing Jordan yeah
yeah and also you know we can hide it if
it gets
yeah if if it gets challenged we can
hide it on it so yeah that's a good
point and honestly I I can see the
engine still preferring it for wide but
I think it's eminently playable for
black
like Knight E7 and then either Knight C6
online G6 this Pawn often gets goes to
F6 just to kind of
prevent white from easily achieving e45
Rook has a very very nice semi-open file
to look forward to and and just
generally these types of you know Timon
of structures
uh tend to be
very very playable for black as long as
you are not under direct attack and now
that the Queens are off the board you
are extremely unlikely to be
uh under any kind of direct attack you
know I think Magnus will be happy
normally when you're kind of struggling
had a couple of bad results you just
want to go back to basics and for him
getting the Queens off when his opponent
can't attack him I think that's the type
of position he will want
um I don't disagree uh I don't disagree
at all maybe Jordan uh not overly happy
with how things are turning or yeah I
mean at least this developments are
getting the Queen's off yeah in the
meantime uh just briefly I will point
out that Fabi did play Queen B2
um I think 1998
I'm still pretty sure Bishop two white
is better but the reason the engine
hates it so much is very very
specifically this idea of Bishop before
and then cd5 and either D6 or G6
which is just winning material
um so black is in in more trouble I
think than
uh he might even immediately realize uh
create A5 has been played by part harm
against uh Rickard sorry heard now has
an important choice to make and we have
some exciting news elsewhere as well so
Anish uh do the version of what we were
talking about he took on D5
uh played Bishop G5 and played B3
straight away without even including H4
before which is honestly quite
understandable uh even though I still
have to wonder why we're not playing C3
here
maybe after C3 Anish will play A4 yeah I
think it's the same position and I I
want to ask
I want to ask the
yeah it's it's actually sort of exactly
as we were giving it and yeah the engine
just likes it for white but it's very
very unclear to me like the engine just
gives white
the sort of the full plus one you would
assume why it has here because white has
more pawns and continues with a 5x6 and
just says I'm not very worried about the
bishop C5 for kjf8 come to play it never
actually leads to anything substantial
but yeah as I said like in a Blitz game
here with black I think I would think
I'm better in a classical gaming as a
strong player I would probably have to
temper my enthusiasm a little bit but
this is not clear to me at all uh in the
open Spanish between uh
uh notibec and Prague we have a version
of the position we're talking about as
well I after Queen E7
matter of fact played Rook fe1 right
Play Bishop B6 H3 or kd8 Bishop C2 G6
so very close to what we're discussing
actually and now uh Nevada played A4 a.m
which is a very I think a very important
part of what white is doing here because
now in particular now that the Rook has
left the A8 Square
uh okay I need to delete all of these
arrows
because I can't draw them apparently uh
trying to get to the to the bottom A6 is
is going to be a very important part of
why it's
uh strategy because otherwise I think
black already is very ready to play G5
before next move
uh look at the Bishops
just trying to lengthen the diagonals
for the Bishops open the G file for the
rook and so on all of those are very
good things
uh A4 B4 interesting point here is I
know maybe not that interesting actually
I was going to say why it seemingly
created a threat against the pawn on A6
and then didn't take it but between A6 I
think five sequence E5 yeah against the
pawn maybe with interest
yeah it looks very very nice for black
so Knight B3 and is played and here uh
Prague after some thought
uh played a very committal uh sequence
he took took and played D5 before
straight away uh because he obviously
had the option at least
of playing I don't know why whether you
you do it immediately or after bcbc but
you can play a6a5 here yeah uh so making
sure it doesn't hang
and then go from there
but maybe white goes through kg1 or
maybe even the immediate Knight D4 and
you might never get a chance to play
d5d4 ever again
uh nd4 is important I think so the front
just goes for it you know for example in
that position after rookie D1 and I
could just ask you what's your next
movement it's not obvious at all as
black
um so okay he's gone for it but the
position is changing it gets very sharp
A6 is still hanging
yeah I want to take that pawn off the
board I don't really see what else you
could make my question is yeah my
question is can we throw in a five
uh and because I think like if we if
we're forcing Bishop A7 here
I am very interested
but I'm not sure if we are because
Bishop takes B3 exists D4 G3 also exists
as a reply so we're giving black a lot
of additional options but just on
General grounds if we if we could just
include A5 display 7 I would be
extremely interested even if simply uh
in let's say in this position I don't
know if this is what black is planning
but looks logical I would like to be
taking on A6 and I would like for my
passer but very very you know simply be
one step further along the way to the
queening square
oh yes very psychological to me but as I
mentioned day five like you need to
calculate all of this stuff yeah Bishop
takes B3 D3 and Knight takes A5 next
move yeah do three in particular and uh
and then
take and uh
doesn't really seem like we'll be in
time to generate some
Cavalier attack on the king side here
yeah it feels like we just I mean we
lose 10 p with our Bishop getting hit uh
Queen C5 may be coming it's it's just
very sharp a 5k played in the meantime
wow very interesting I was gonna ask if
not A5 if we just take on D4 first yeah
exactly the collaboration uh but with
the pawn on A4 so what happens yeah why
why was this
unsatisfactory
um
I'm slightly confused unless there's
something now
to do with just planting the bishop of
D5 maybe and
going for Queen G5
it's hard to believe
maybe bishop D5
5 is one idea you could also go for some
sort of like Rook D2 followed by Queen
C5 Type stuff uh trying to maybe put
some pressure on the F2 Pawn Rook E2
here may be playable yeah it doesn't
look uh let me put it like this it
doesn't look horrible for black but I
also don't quite understand why this is
supposed to equalize
and maybe you didn't
uh going down yeah I mean it's an
important one even let's say if you
imagine some kind of weird scenario and
I say weird because I don't currently
see any way for this to happen
but let's say we somehow lose the pawn
on E5 but we stabilize it's not equal
it very much isn't equal in particular
if it's already an endgame with the
queens of yeah like the the a Pawn on A5
against the C Pawn on C7 we are not
going to be offering any draws we might
not win but we're going to be quite
happy about those positions
uh so yeah interesting choice here
okay and now Bishop takes B3 as we
thought uh and it was very logical I
guess you could make an argument for D3
as well
um yeah
off the board very quickly yeah D3 and
then maybe bishop takes F2 because my
original intention was to take on B3 but
then I think you do lose the pawn on A6
and you haven't really uh just upon Down
Still yeah I mean
Blake doesn't lose this every single
time you you definitely save some of
these positions because as is very kind
of normal for open Spanish is when the
Knight remains rooted to the F3 Square
The Colony five is a target
T3 is very much hanging I also simply
want to play Rook f8 next move and then
uh sort of file on the pile on the
pressure with maybe bishop D5 trying to
undermine the Knight and just win this
Pawn back
I wouldn't be shocked if there was
enough counter play here for black 2.
to be okay-ish but there is also an
option of Bishop 2 let's say
uh which way do you take that's the yeah
win no Queen takes I might take on D3
yeah you might take on D3 yeah exactly
which is why maybe King and then we take
on B3 Bishop A6 and once again make some
move like we should be five here and
then look at V8 yes we're down one but
the king is not very safe
still needs to be brought back into the
fold somehow Queen C5 Knight A5 ideas
exist
it's not very clear but I think the
bigger question has to be what's
happening after Bishop B3
[Music]
I assume this is not really a great
option
and what's the count at the end even if
I just take take and I don't know play
g53 like that black is just completely
fine unless we're going up I don't want
to entertain this is white
so we we get here and I mean we played
D3 here and we're I think both of us
quite happy about it but you also have
to wonder yeah can I just take
everything C3 is hanging yeah can I just
go after everything
okay let's say I move my Bishop Bishop
A2
and if you take I go e six
and now I think
yeah and this is kind of what I just
want to describe this a little bit for
the viewers because it looks like we've
achieved a great deal here with white
now we now have a very nice passer I
more or less automatically play this
it's not the only move I can I can
definitely imagine something like King
G7 being an additional option here
because EF if the Queens come off I'm
not that scared about it it takes F7 uh
but the larger point is yes you
generally get thought that Queens are
poor blockers
but in this position in particular the
the two ways for white to
uh challenge this block would be Rook D1
D7
or somehow getting Knight on F3 to
either D5 or C6
and Rook D1 I think we're quite happy to
go King G7 and Rook D7 isn't really very
much a threat yet in the meantime black
is two pawns up and wants to play like
Knight 694 or something on that six
Knight B4
and Rook D7 will be very very happy to
take twice
uh what if I played kind of the long
four compensation if I just play Rook
ac1 take the C3 Pawn off the board and
then just sit on a position maybe H4 but
then I think we've
I think black is just fine right because
what will happen is we'll get here you
will have to allow the Knight trade
right I don't know I could maybe Queen
somewhere do I take the pawn back can I
take it even let's say let's say I let's
say I ignore the fact that maybe it'll
get two is sensible here my claim here
is that simply I will not lose this
position
and I think it's a reasonable claim yes
I understand it will be a little bit
worrying because white if you're
completely stabilize you will start kind
of digging with H4 H5 and the pawn H6
might become a bit soft yeah but
you know to get here along I think black
would have played more ambitiously along
the way but even this
let's say
foreign
I think we always have enough count to
play because of just how monstrous is
strong with respond B6 says to not have
to
worry too much
um
so yeah I I don't think this is bad and
then and then we also have the uh the D3
option D3 Queen E4 Knight A5 let's say
straight to anyway
but now you have a move and yeah we need
to find a good move here but I assume it
exists
that would have been tremendous yeah
that would have given us I think a large
Advantage straight off the bat but yeah
yeah can we can we just do this attack
of two
prepare maybe Knight C6 or queen C6 and
if you play six my my idea was just to
take and put the King on night shade and
claim that
h8 is going to be a safe enough Square
the way the pieces are
yeah I mean it's chances for both sides
here just uh very very complex position
um
we're headed towards that okay and in
our top two games of well on my screen
they're not really the top two games uh
the bottom A5 is gone in the game
between uh Wesley and Vincent Wesley
opted to play Bishop C4 to really for C5
which is honestly a bit of a weird one
for me because it looked like black was
doing it anyway
and I'm not sure and I'm not sure we
need Bishop C4 in every single position
I guess he stopped that Queen B5 idea
that we uh we had I'm not sure how
relevant that was yeah so 45 he dropped
it back to G3 and then played 92 Knight
F3 in which before
and uh
yeah
you know I I'm maybe still speaking
white it's weird yeah it was interesting
that he didn't want to capture this Pawn
on A6 on the last move he didn't want to
regain uh the material balance
maybe just because it takes pieces off
the board and black is so cramped this
benefits black yeah I think that's
exactly I think he feels that his
position is definitely good enough not
to trade
as beautiful a bishop as this one on C4
for the bishopon C8 for one measly or
only six
which buff also creates a very concrete
threat of E5 V6 which would currently be
just straight up winning despite
seemingly blundering the the bishop on
F4
and go EF we go to day C7 yeah and we
crash through Seattle Quincy one you can
block yeah we can go we can go back to a
check
yeah so I guess the coin moves yeah I
don't know she seeks Basics one of those
squares
D6 here isn't a movie that just looks
too ugly I don't really want to
calculate it but
um is there a refutation well this is
material though no oh maybe not yeah
because you take with the bishop yeah
and then yeah yeah
I'm just worried off the D6 and actually
in all of these positions that there's
some Bishop takes H6 Queen G6 but I
guess the fact that he published by four
last move without
um yeah this is the this is the question
because
it was an option on the previous move
but
yeah the Assumption has to be there's no
follow-up here for some reason after
Queen H6 Queen maybe black is in time to
play Queen C6 or something and and
stabilize the inclusion of
uh the inclusion of uh before and D6
what does it do to that position GH
check
dates Queen six is no longer available
but if black puts a bishop on F5 if it's
never checked me yeah yeah blocking this
diagonal generally just
holds
and then we're a piece up so holds is
maybe not the word to be using
yeah still very sharp so still very very
sharp once again we have a very
interesting round in progress
uh I'm not sure about you Peter but I
think I'd take white I'm normally a bit
materials materialistic but here it
feels like minimal risk and yeah I I
already I already also mailed
my colors to the mass tentatively here
yeah I
the point only seeks like if although I
want to say if we have to bail out we
always have Rook A1 but honestly
afterwards frequent V6 or queen C6 we'll
have Knight C7 so maybe bailing out is
not as easy as I originally anticipated
how do we
go about generating threads here good
question G4 G5 I'm not even entirely
entirely joking wow black is passive
enough I think for us to at least
consider it if it's manager of G4 would
be on the board already just uh
yeah it makes some sense I guess another
kind of lesson
1976 is once again a decent reply sort
of killing off to a degree there's
Bishop on C4
attacking the other one Queen C6 chosen
which was the
uh the other option that we named
at least g4's off the cards now because
of Bishop B7 yeah that that is really no
longer an option
um so what do we do Bishop D5
I guess we choose between Queen B6 and
B5
uh and even if we choose B6 it's not a
loss of a Tempo because what we've
actually succeeded in doing is we've
given ourselves a bit of attempt with
Knight C7 because
white will of course have to pay
attention not to trade this guy for a
night
interesting yeah I like C6 actually the
more we think about it superficially as
you say it did look like a not Square
where you can get attacked but
is this guy yeah yeah
if we could plant it on e4 or D5 or F5
and it'll be game over but can't get
there
I'm a few times this is the gestures
Rook D1 just say to Black okay I'm gonna
at least keep you in your place for a
few more moves but 97.96 black Superstar
yeah we are we are coming out of the
corner aren't we a little bit you know
and and this really returns me to sort
of the earlier part of the game where
like if I published before here
don't you don't you steal place if I
pretty sure I do yeah so we go Queen D3
I assume you take only five anyway
because that was basically what the
entire previous play was like aimed at
right so we get here
and then I mean first of all 57 is
unplayable but let's ignore that for a
second I think we'd be five together C6
to compare
but we have
massively more options for squares for
this piece and very very specifically
like
I think I like it only four much more
than I like it on F3
yeah actually in the current game
position I forgot that the Knight had
already come from D2 I was going to say
maybe Knight D2 is an interesting movie
yeah yeah you're right I agree with you
I agree with you you need to move it
somewhere because it's the only piece
white has which currently really is
doing nothing
at all whatsoever
nothing aggressive yeah
and
we needed to generate threats
so I'm curious why it went here as a as
a matter of urgency
in the game yeah Bishop D5 player do you
think there's any chance at all if a
repetition after Queen B5
Bishop C4 and C6
depends on how Vincent is feeling about
about his position because
uh he's not doing very well in the
tournament but that could be an argument
for both right yeah that could be an
argument for you know he would very much
like maybe to win a game of chess
somewhere which I'm pretty sure is true
but it's also definitely an argument for
uh you know let's kind of stop the
bleeding make a draw again especially
with black definitely not a poor result
yeah uh under most circumstances and
just kind of restart tomorrow with the
white pieces
yeah I think it might be important here
as well
um trying to think of the queen B5 Queen
G6 isn't an option because it Bishop B7
it was a bit scary but otherwise quenchy
six I think would be quite strong but
um you know we get deflected so if you
can get away with Queen D5 it feels like
you gain time and then you hit with
Knight C7 next move if white doesn't
repeat
yeah
so yeah uh maybe that internal dialogue
of uh we'll see how it should inspires
yeah interestingly not a bit quite
quickly I should have went for this
which really doesn't look to me like
it's any kind of a winning attempt yeah
we're not just going to see things okay
so slightly after Queen C7 Queen C maybe
not even slightly uh I was briefly
interested in the midnight before just
to like win the pawn on C3 but I guess
after something like Queen A4 taking on
C3 is
probably just impossible because Europe
going to get overloaded and let them
before it's going to drop
yeah
and I said but yeah that there has to be
a way just to make a
very comfortable draw here with black
I'm playing for more playing ambitiously
with D3 Queen D2
yeah I don't know
because this is hanging Queen H6 95
ideas exist rookie three ideas are yeah
also on the table it doesn't feel like
you're actually running
uh
yeah too much risk with white I think I
think the reason he's thinking is maybe
this idea or would you say I don't know
which one is more precise and the point
being that
we actually kind of like the seventh
square for the queen you know
um and we want to go GTX G3 here in the
night before and if white has to play
CD4 is just an immediate draw because
they're like this is just a very very
equal position
I think we're headed in this direction
uh possible here and it's a yeah a
decent result for both uh interesting
game
yeah this bishop takes C5 idea still not
too impressed I've got to say anything
but um you know he was never risking too
much you know Travis correct uh I I got
uh somewhat corrected in this line
because Queen A4
93 and black probably is doing really
really well but Queen B1 yeah Queen B1
is very strong yeah I just didn't get
there first try with a very very same
idea of
similar idea proxy one and then uh
now it gets dropped
how how is Anish Gary doing because uh
it's a structure with the pawn on C4
rather than those that we were talking
about and to me I still feel super shaky
for black if white can time Bishop E4
correctly
uh just to get rid of a Defender
yeah C4 currently currently what is
probably bothering him is that this move
I believe is playable yes and it's not
just a pawn it also sort of undermines
the white structure a little bit
seems like a massive trades are
on the horizon which is something that
Anish will not be very interested in I
would be tempted slightly by 1965 Queen
E5 Rook takes C4 there but I don't think
we're if the bish1 G5 wasn't hanging
then maybe but
yeah this doesn't look like made right
because I will probably run towards the
seven F6
yeah Queen A6 King d8 and we run yeah
and it feels like we probably get to
where we're running towards
yeah number six F2 is an annoying uh
rejoinder for black as well in these
positions so yeah yeah some calculation
there's also the H7 Pawn up for grabs at
some point but I don't really want to
yeah I don't think that I don't think
it's that relevant just yet
yeah
it's black threatening to take on F3
with the Rook maybe in some positions
yeah Bishop uh
uh hang on in that line after Rook C4
Bishop C4 there is Bishop B7 Checkers
okay we did we did miss that I don't
know about my idea I don't know if that
is very clear I guess we can even throw
in rugby one check here weirdly and then
take on E5
yeah so this has to be played
better okay so not Knight takes E5 then
yeah it should be seven
checks and captures I forgot whoops
so Bishop E4 definitely on the radar if
if you can play I guess black has to
play in Knight B6 or probably wants to
play Knight B6 just to hold everything
together when she shakes maybe maybe
Quincy six Rooks c56 Rook C4 again yeah
but then Bishop C4
yeah I stopped I stopped here and I
thought this looks horrible but it
doesn't actually look horrible at all
it's like a mirror image of the same
tactic same clearance you know
yeah maybe Queen C6
um yeah yeah it's plenty of very very
exciting positions in this round again I
will just mention that Mukesh after
Queen B2 could not find anything better
than just playing Queen C8 and uh
this looks horrible like we take twice
and kind of win right feels like you're
losing on material and you're about to
get checkmated H4 is definitely uh
findable now oh yeah
like against any of these moves like 96
would just you know if you move windmill
windmills windmill dunk H4 onto the
board and go from there yeah
uh yeah yeah how would you survive here
not 96 I just don't see what else
yeah it looks looks horrendous yeah Fabi
has been thinking for a while but yeah I
very difficult to imagine how you don't
take like what else would you do
maybe not g6h4 DC do we have to
calculate it all there H5 Rook F5
oh I don't know which squares but I like
yeah I don't know maybe Queen G4
if five I don't know if this helps yeah
500 maybe now I go to C3
and The Rook on F5 is also very stupid
or I don't know Queen G4 maybe very
sophisticated yeah Queen G4 actually
wins a piece right yeah weirdly maybe
Black's best bet is to just give the
piece CB and just uh or in that position
yeah and
I hope that we don't get mated oh you're
just a piece down yeah it's not it
doesn't feel like kind of a sacrifice
that works out yeah seven or queen D3
and then King E2 and then eventually I
will collect uh it's not as if White's
uh King is in too much trouble ever so
yeah
just says Rook D5 here which I blundered
which means that D4 is not the best
square but I'm still pretty certain uh
H4 is fine so we go I guess we go to C3
then
yeah
it's really hot yeah we'll see we'll
we'll we'll you know burn the bridge
when we when we come to it but it's not
really the only way to play this
position either like I I don't really
see much wrong about snow or
uh in in just playing see the xd5 and
playing kind of a dryer
conversion Style
Bishop takes
F150 okay
put the light on D4 and
win slower Rook C1 am I creating any
counter play at all
some but I don't think it's enough
because like you need two questions I I
blended that check okay
blundered that check
at least you can try and yeah you can
pretend yeah I would very much like not
to play she takes G5 yeah
I would definitely would much prefer to
play H4 and just win straight away but
[Music]
the second part of that seems trickier
than I originally anticipated
yeah I was wondering about flicking in
B4 just to get the Rook away from any
Rook F5 swings
like B4 or C7 and then H4 just are we
worried about this at all ah this is
Maybe
yeah otherwise
otherwise we do maybe yeah otherwise I
like geological grade Julia and just go
H4 here we really don't care about
Bishop takes C4 we'll we'll just give
mate like
this is not going to be fast enough
I wonder if we're still winning after B4
route C4 just take it and it's coming
back to B2 and
um Rook CH4 but yeah why calculate this
yeah we'll prefer not to do this because
yeah this feels like we could be missing
something I don't quite know what but it
does feel like we could be missing
something of Queen G4
E5 def I don't know it looks looks like
it might be winning as well yeah I don't
yeah I tend to agree with you but yeah
Fabio I guess he's just trying to pick a
variation where it's kind of minimal
risk and he's kind of uh he can
calculate his way to Victory or just
get that long-term Advantage
um
without uh too much to work on how about
any other games Queen A5 it looks like
was played in the Rapport against
maxillary game yeah and Richard took on
F6 with uh with the Knight and dropped
the bishop back to E3
uh Rook FDA and I think this is going to
be
your kind of a car or structured quite
likely because if black wanted to play
F5 he could have done this here yeah but
the position after takes takes in
community too
is maybe a tiny tiny bit better for
white right because you you end up with
a kind of an isolini either on D6 or on
D5 yeah which is eventually going to be
reasonably well blocked by
94.
and it's a bit of a free roll yeah I was
going to blunder with Queen B5 on the
last move Bishop takes C3
yeah that would be
are unnecessary so I think very much
indicates that he wants this structure
change rather than the other one let's
say 85 maybe even Rook D5
Queen C2 yeah uh Rook 88
and eventually we'll play h6a h605
yeah it feels like black isn't
necessarily struggling too much
dynamically you're doing very well so
the pawn structure not too relevant
yeah doesn't look doesn't look bad at
all I think I'd happily take black here
yeah just despite this light yeah I
don't know about taking but I think
white is not really like if I just go
away three and then start swapping
everything down along the G file I don't
think why it is yeah we haven't done
enough to be worse I don't think yeah
but definitely not but I just mean I
might be okay with either side like just
definitely not too I'm not too concerned
and very sadly let me see if I can find
a way to bring up that position
or you've already seen the move but I
think both of us would have been
instantly making the same move here
right yeah
this is a very very typical Sicilian
thing where uh G5 is what you almost
always just start with just to make sure
that the the bishop 25 is
impossible to challenge and if that
trade ever happens it happens on your
terms with B5 detect energy takes C5 and
just generally like gaining as much
space on the queen on the king side as
possible is a very good business
practice for for black in all of these
positions
yeah this looks exactly like what you
don't want against Magnus
exactly and I guess this is similar to
that uh structure that we just mentioned
with the double death ones for black it
doesn't matter that this structure is
compromised if we take on E5
um now as white because
White's majority takes an age to get
motoring black has a very clear plan and
whites minor pieces
uh it's just so stuck takes them
especially the White Knight a bunch of
moves to
to kind of uh yeah recircuit itself
I I don't know if we're already like
the engine actually apparently still
prefers white a little bit but yeah long
term I think these types of structure is
very often start favoring black
uh because I think that the the play on
the king side is just much easier to
organize and just much more intuitively
and understandable whereas
what we're doing on the queen side for
white is not at all obvious to me like
Chad says Knight needs to be on D3 yeah
so you could you could actually you know
invest three Tempe
into getting it all to D3 but even let's
say let's say we just allow you to do
all that
and then we just very commonly go 97.
I still don't quite know why we're
supposed to be
uh better with white I guess we're okay
like King just looking E3 and then maybe
eventually we start
preparing and pushing for situshi for
but I'm still
probably just picking black
yeah it feels like you can't be in any
serious trouble as black and the
audience played a move I've got to say
Peter I'm not a fan of at all can you
one no it's a sicilian move like
Sicilian players they play King B1 on
autopilot but with the Queen's off
I I disagree with this I disagree with
this and yeah not just because Chad told
me that now black is better and
uh and even our engine kind of started
doubting White's position but it just
feels like
it's irrelevant
yeah
and in fact even even in this immediate
position doing something like this I
would actually understand just get it
over to E3 so that it participates in
the game yeah
uh whereas yeah pushing it away from the
center by playing King B1 looks very
very
odd to me I guess the only justification
is he wants to play D2 Rook HD1 without
walking into Bishop F4 but
do you base but it's just very very
empty right it's not really generating
you can get them there and you're still
not threatening anything also you should
actually will be hanging like H5 H4 here
yeah
yeah it can be one I don't understand
yeah especially if we're trying to clear
a square to get the white knight to D3
later we could have used B4 rather than
clearing the square on C1
I'm struggling to understand yeah I
think I think it burns the tempo and
also makes your position ever so
slightly worse than it was before like I
think it's counterproductive I think
reasons for the white king
being better on C1 rather than on B1
are quite easy to formulate and the
other way around I'm not so sure yeah
yeah without being harsh reloading this
is not his type of position stylistic no
not really very much art magnus's uh Ali
so it can be one a bit of an odd one
and uh okay are we gonna see one game
disappear soon and do satoroph maybe uh
or maybe this game even only I mean zero
repetitions so far Queen B5 chosen but
this is the fresh position they haven't
even done this once okay so we don't
know what Wesley feels about this for
Wesley it's been a very quiet tournament
so far right he's uh
uh yeah I've done five for played five
Drew five
very solid seemed I think more or less
entirely untroubled so far but he often
is like he he generally is one of the
most solid and
uh
[Music]
I'm struggling to read three players
yeah risk of us if he can be yesterday
was impressive uh I've got to say oh
yeah oh yeah that was far from a
risk-free position but he found a way to
kind of guide it towards uh Karma Waters
and yeah in this position I'm just
struggling I've got to say if we can't
use G6 because of Bishop B7 F5 doesn't
look so stable right now
um
well where do we go with the White Queen
Queen D2 lines up a sacrifice maybe but
it should be seven again maybe even now
yeah
how about Queen F5 let's try one uh just
temporarily I can't hit you oh yeah we
won which before yeah that's the idea I
guess
it should be seven again I'm gonna five
blade by the way um okay
uh you know we need a good answer now
I'm wondering whether we take on the
sevenish flavor of D1 just at least the
materialistic way yeah
yeah here with the queen on G2 I
wouldn't have been so worried because we
could have just played Knight C7 uh but
when you were taking on the seven with
the Rogue cam
I'm much less happy about things
yeah I don't think I have a good reply
here I think this is just better for
white
so you have to do something else
but it should be four is a bit scary at
least I'm sure computers aren't too too
worried they'll just say okay the White
Queen goes back and after G6 but
um yeah how do we make this
unless it's something super clever like
uh Queen B6 which before Queen G6 but
that
feels too convoluted hmm
yeah
I just yeah Chad said there's not I
guess maybe I can you know armed with
the knowledge that this is playable I
guess I can figure out why maybe maybe
we go Knight C7
Rook D7 Queen C8
question mark question mark
and if I just defend my queen or
yeah I've just been given a Hint by our
lovely producer uh I'm not sure maybe
this one's playable as well but
might be something even more clever
after D1 D6
with this intention I uh wow
I consider this for a second but I kind
of gave up here which I assume is
sort of one move too early
that's crazy geometry
yeah the bishop caught in the crossfire
this would be so easy to miss I mean oh
yeah yeah I don't think I'd see this in
most classical games
yeah I don't know like I'm I'm
definitely showing off with Queen B8 I
suspect Queen G7 is also playable
we don't need to be although I'm gonna
say maybe it's not
maybe 95 C4 I should keep some material
here and I have to play mb8 Bishop takes
d69 yeah yeah there's another six in the
end
you know Queen V8 I mean it's nice right
you've played B4 as well stop any
um yeah yeah it's a it's a very cute
move
it's a very cute move I just wasn't sure
if it was strictly speaking it required
but maybe it even is yeah I mean it
makes it even better with a tactic like
this maybe the momentum is on black side
you've got the past Acorn long term uh
White has to be a bit careful
uh wow okay so Bishop B7 I wonder how
fine the margins are here if we don't
play Bishop B7 if we assume that for
example if it's in his calculations
stops at Rook D1 and
like us the first time rounds we should
be seven played by by Vincent By the way
Vincent is playing very confidently
today
yeah and this is one of the kind of a
good things we do know about Vincent is
that
he appears to be a very very
level-headed
young man with a very decent
sort of a
Sportsman's
nervous system where you know he's not
he's not very easily tilted he's not
very easy to shaken by setbacks because
yesterday must have been a setback
yeah he defended the very dangerous in a
very difficult position extremely well
and then sort of lost it all over again
in the third time control in the
eventual sort of Eternal time trouble
that
appears
uh past move 16 and after his
performance of the world rapid he's
going to be full of confidence getting
silver that's so impressive and
um yeah to play Bishop B7 that quickly
I've got to say uh yeah this is this is
a good sign yeah right he
it might be honestly what I was what I
was arguing for is maybe not that stupid
either because my point was if let's say
you play you do want to do on G4 or
maybe three or what originally one of
those moves but 23 I was worried about
Rook d8 just yeah that was that was my
large my large point and in case of sure
I can actually force it as well by
playing G6 and then
ruk d8 and here H6 is hanging so I'm
less happy so I I was also looking to
maybe improve on it somehow maybe if we
can C4 after Queen D3 I don't know if
that kicks you to in a worse Square yeah
yeah that is relevant that is
a sensible idea yeah
but also as you say G4 is hanging in
that line so uh Rook d8 I think you have
time for yeah I just don't like the idea
of thinking with the bishop it feels
like we're misplacing our stuff a little
bit but G4 is like H3
I just need a decent move here and I
don't think I will be doing too poorly
maybe even weird Logistics G5 because
this this remains such a stupid piece
that you know you can get a position
like this and play it yeah and if I
don't know if that's horrible
yeah
but we're getting infected in C4 as well
maybe it was extra extra good
um
you know uh but we're getting very
carried away let's briefly maybe uh take
a look at some other positions and then
go or on a short break uh so this is
what's happening in uh uh so kymer uh
Jing versus Lebanon is
dick has a nice little
safe pressure I guess because uh the
five are very interesting so which pay
five was played
uh my wife played Knight C3 and then
simply Knight takes d500
and white very very importantly got to
play for a five and not allow a 7a5 from
black meaning that there's no
outpost on before for the Knight on G5
and now we have kind of pleasant
pressure because you also have this very
useful Square on C5 for the night
I'm very surprised
I've got to say A6 is black just feels
really kind of unnecessary yeah this
white really threatening to play A6
himself it doesn't feel that way sure
yeah I think I tend to agree with you
yeah we you could definitely find
reasons not to do it yeah yeah uh I knew
she did play this before and Arjun is
now thinking
uh notibeck is trying to keep the game
afloat by uh after Brook dc7 he's played
Rook a1a4 meaning that if black simply
takes there is no immediate way to take
these guys off the board
that is not to say that black is much
worse after
I don't know even 1986
yeah uh
very often like nobody ever does that
but like even this position
is very often just a draw
because this Knight is a very very nice
blockading night the polony 5 is it does
degeneratively produce additional
counter play but of course there is no
need for for Prague to sort of wave a
white flag here
as hard as all that you can see five
seems playable
for instance yeah Queen C5 is good maybe
just root d8 as well
just get that last piece yeah there's
absolutely no need for for Prague to beg
here so I think he's completely fine uh
Jordan played uh King B1 Rook hg8 A4 B4
and is now thinking I guess he now goes
19992 C1 and maybe
uh D3 but generally moving the pawns
from from A6 and B5 to A5 and before
should be in Black's favor because it's
going to be much harder to attack them
you know on the dark squares
yeah I like where this is going for
Magnus I think Magnus will be
quite enjoying
uh how this is progressing yeah agreed a
very weird little move there chosen by
Parham I guess stopping Queen B5 but he
could have
yeah I don't know does that mean he
doesn't want to play the 65.
how much can we read into his decision
not to play either F5 or G5 here maybe
he's just uh asking why what his next
move is because Rook fd1 is still D5 as
possible 94. I like 94. I don't know why
I don't know why we're giving white such
an easy ride to play that move actually
yeah that seems like a very very logical
next month
and yeah I don't really want to take but
if I take you
um I think I think I just do this and
yeah that is not to say that the
position of the G5 has decreased in
quality dramatically I think it's still
playable for black but I
definitely feel that giving white this
trade so easily you always have to worry
about it easier D5 for example you have
to start worrying about Queen E3 here
and that's also there yeah there's also
also that as well yeah it's just a bit
specifying frankly I think he uh was
maybe kind of
interested in stopping Queen B5 from
happening but I don't think it was as
important
an idea is all that so yeah not sure
about that and this is the position in
5V versus good cash our entire line
appeared on the board Fabi played H4
quite quickly in fact GTX H5 you get
five the queen did go to C3 as we
suspected 97 and I think the problem for
good cash is
among other things we can just go beat
the AC for yeah and we should we can
claim that we're also Material off
I'm also very interested about Brooke H
for Peter yeah 4-h3 I don't know
just going no it's just poor it's just
very very poor for black
yeah
maybe black has to play F6 there that's
ugly
yeah
and now worse comes to West we take on
C4 we just take and we like we we will
still have some kind of an attack on the
king side eventually but
we're we have a reasonably healthy extra
Pawn on C4 here The Rook on the five it
doesn't Inspire much confidence
yeah I wouldn't be surprised if this was
just arthurly lost
yeah
all right this I think concludes the
Roundup and we should let's make a kind
of a mental note slash promise to our
viewers that when we come back we do
take a look at the challenges because
we've been completely ignoring the
challengers so far
uh we'll be back in I don't know five
seven ten minutes whatever happens
happens
uh see you then see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
there you know
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
I know it's wrong
I don't care
[Music]
the fire is strong but I don't care
[Music]
[Music]
later
[Music]
the damage is done
but I don't care
[Music]
all I ever wanna be is
your skin
for yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
think about it later
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello and welcome back this is the
second segment of our coverage today of
round six of both the Masters and
challengers in the third steel 2023 if I
can say a tournament and as promised
we're coming back with the Masters
where uh Mustafa ilmas so far was in the
clear lead on four out of five and he is
playing uh White today against
uh Thomas bertson
uh what do we think about
this position
yeah I mean there's a couple of things
we should note so it is a hanging poem
position with uh d4c4 for white looks
like you've got the maximum uh in terms
of the White Knight on B5 it can never
be challenged long term it feels like
white should be doing very well because
of that piece and the black A7 points a
Target but Knight F4 is coming Black's
Bishops are pointed towards the king
is slightly concerned here as white I
don't know if it is it's unclear what
white does next so it feels like we've
achieved a lot but how do we stand the
Blackness exactly uh it feels like maybe
it's time to uh actually invest some uh
some time and attention into
making sure with the counter play on the
king side doesn't materialize or at
least if it materializes it's not as
uh threatening as it could be in some
other cases and what are you saying
about the Knight on B5 being uh very
very difficult to challenge is true but
uh
uh I'm a bit surprised by how seemingly
how much the engine lies this for white
it wouldn't have been at all clear to me
that we're doing
uh you know such a stellar job here with
uh
A7 will be weak in end games but this is
still quite far from any kind of an end
game and you know things that are about
to start on the king side do appear to
be quite real
plenty of play left this much is I think
very very clear that so you know this
game is
um far from decided could could still go
in all kinds of different directions
yeah he's played Queen B3 I like this
just meeting Knight F4 with uh Bishop F1
very calm your message in general is a
very good Defender so um yeah we'll see
but yeah this this movie I do like this
move I do like it's uh it shows very
good uh
uh sort of vision of the board in
general like maybe making a uh a queen
side move which is a very useful
defensive move on the king side is
generally a good sign when you see ideas
like this and maybe in some cases you
could be somewhat interested in which P3
Bishop A3 Queen A3 yeah uh trying to
bring those end games that I was talking
about closer because you will have to
worry about the A7 Pawn even in Game of
any kind and [ __ ] does appear on the
board
uh what do we have elsewhere we have
a very sharp position in uh
begin between Ilitch and ajiban but yeah
it does look like it's sort of sharp in
Only One Direction really
this has gone kind of off the rails here
a little bit for ajiban it began as a
classical Kings Indian and then ajiban
went for the
uh takes uh rookie f3c6 line which
uh has I think a bit of a dodgy
reputation
um
but
you remember exactly why I think
isn't this where this happens no I think
what is one of the main moves I think
this is where this happens right this
stage five night the five line is from
here yeah yes yes but uh recently black
hasn't been playing Knight H5 after gh1
uh I think there are other moves you can
start with D5 or you can uh just play
Knight D7 and
yeah and what really which is done
instead is just to move Bishop C1 G5
which is interesting to me because you
know it looks like it very much runs
sort of head on into Queen B6 with all
kinds of counter play using all of the
pins and attacking B2 and so on but
clearly both of them know why Queen B6
doesn't work here
which is why I debunked this
and then this and then this but by this
point all of this has
backfire to a really spectacular degree
because uh things have started going
back got traded and
Now by move 23 there is no semblance of
an attack for black on the on the king
side bite
is entirely stable on the king side
these nights are kind of horrible in the
one on the five looks very very
beautiful
tempted to say this is winning for white
yeah with best play it does feel if you
have the time to kind of play a luxury
like B3 then it feels like you've got
full control and yeah like you say at
some point White's Queen is going to
come over country two queen H3
a couple of very nice positions for
black elsewhere uh Joe here cinderoff is
it's actually surprising to me that the
engine doesn't like it even more than it
does but this is obviously a very very
pleasant position it's a kind of a once
again we return to the fact that this is
how people play the Joko piano these
days like the old
very very old school
and uh
honestly it does feel like a bit of a
diagram of
uh kind of an exemplary game from the
black side which is
you know this is how you react to Bishop
G4 Bishop G5 with page four and this is
why you aren't supposed to be afraid of
it
um seems like everything has gone
swimmingly for black their file is now
open the King on G8 I think is actually
maybe safer than linking on G1 by this
point the bishop C5 is very strong I
guess we go
94. maybe actually even King H2 and
Knight G3 fg3 is not such a bad
development for white in some cases but
yeah I'm preferring black hair every day
of the week and I'm surprised the engine
doesn't
uh doesn't like it as much as I do and
somewhat sadly for us
uh things have gone
think slightly
pear-shaped for lean robbers today and
yeah two pawns down I wanted to I wanted
to say she is very unlucky with the
bearings but I allowed you I now realize
it's just an incredibly strong field
because she does appear to be playing
2600s every day
uh apart from actually in round five
before the resume because she was
playing uh against Thomas Barrison who
is not the 2600. uh but yeah it's just a
field full of 2600 frankly and yeah we
we're somehow too down without really
much to show for it
uh how did this happen that was an H4 H5
uh Cairo where people do these days tend
to Gambit stuff away and already on move
oh seven Alina here played B4 and black
I think very wisely decided not to take
Quincy 186 C3 Queen B6
and uh yeah you have to wonder
uh if white could play a2a5 here I think
white is potentially like strategically
winning because black will never find
a good Pawn break but the way it
happened in the game
once your queen size structure starts
being
being destroyed it's the King on E8 is
very safe and it's just very difficult
to
uh to figure out where your counter play
is going to be coming from C4 is a cute
move creating a third of Rook A3 uh
Knight F5 C5 once again reestablishing
that threat I was momentarily I was very
shaken by the idea of allowing Knight
takes D4 and then I realized Rook A3
exists again because of 8 was locked out
but Alexander very carefully just played
Queen C7 which would be 297 and white is
now
uh gambiting stuff away on both flanks
with not really very much to show for it
um
I guess we can play Bishop C3 which
probably forces Rook A7
and then perhaps we can play something
like Knight F4
but I'm still struggling to
understand where the long-term
compensation will come from
yeah I guess you could kind of triple up
on the beef and the bee Pawn Force black
into total passivity but
yeah what next you're right uh Knight F4
black and
play G6 yeah I guess black hero is happy
to Castle uh sooner or later and just
play Rook B8 and
defend everything I guess maybe the
question will be whether black can make
progress with such passive pieces
when the time comes but I think
eventually you can probably prepare
seven or six somewhere or something
along those lines it doesn't look very
promising uh I'm Bishop A3 this I
completely missed this might be at least
a potential explanation for previous
play somehow I yeah I just ignored this
option altogether but now the Rook on A2
is locked out we probably want to play
Knight C3 next move
although even that like if you imagine
black just casting here waiting for
Knight C3 and then giving up on A3 and
taking on D4
this looks like it cannot possibly be
any good for white frankly unless H5 is
saying there's maybe some contemplator
also uh what happened is hanging though
yeah yeah
Queen A5 uh maybe just to attack two
pieces yeah Queen A5 I thought we will
be playing you have to play Bishop
before somewhere six maybe yeah at least
I might yeah get my Rook out now
yeah at least she's creating some
threats some comes to play King G1 hero
I guess it needs to get out the pin and
Knight C3 is
lately in the air yeah this is this is
still not as clear as I as I'd
anticipated and uh Which Way 3 does seem
to be an important uh uh an important
Motif to
prevent black from very easily
stabilizing by bringing that route back
to A7
on other boards we have uh uh jurgus
uh enjoying a very very nice gruntful
then game the the kind the kind of a
Greenfield end game you generally very
much would not like
to have
from the black side from the bishop B3
grenfeld which has been a kind of a bane
of my existence for my entire career
I've never really liked this particular
system and
I've tried more or less everything
against it and the line I recommend in
the course is
I think a very good indication of how I
feel about this particular grenfeld
because I I ended up giving
via whatever move order you choose I
ended up giving this line
Rook C1 we go How does it go Bishop G4
D5 D5 this this thing okay
yeah which uh basically by
uh by move 15 you're very often just one
or two points down with absolute Mayhem
on the board which is very very
difficult to control for either side uh
specifically because I I've always
really hated defending end games like
this even though the engine does hold
them in in most cases like I've looked
at this end game the engine does suggest
that if you play precisely you're okay
but
you're never ever fighting for well
three results against players who know
what they're doing
and I never really sort of enjoyed the
process at all and uh but why Charlie I
blame cram Nick I was gonna say yeah
luckily not every opponent is uh
Vladimir he won't be able to grind us
down every time but yes yes I agree
difficult there's definitely definitely
reappeared in large part because of his
efforts so yeah blaming economic here is
entirely justifiable
and yeah the the end game we have on the
board right now is sort of exactly the
kind of an end game that I'm
talking about
E3 rugby seven a three is a clever move
by the way because Knight on A6 has no
squares and A3 I don't know if it's the
best one but I like it because
um
just making it as difficult as possible
for black to bring this into the game
makes a ton of sense and now after B7
the only thing we need to be sure about
is that we have a way to control P5
because I think against the past let's
say black very much wants to play B5 and
then Ruby six
because now there is a target
but if we can control this counter play
somehow
uh we have full control over the one
open file here it's unlikely to ever
change because the C7 square is
controlled by the bishop
we have a much better much more
centralized King which is useful in an
op in an end game we can eventually
start creating passers in the center
they're just annoying in games even if
they're not that bad they're just very
very annoying
uh what else do we have we have
a very sharp position
in uh Mishra versus tobatabai from
this is a very recognizable structure in
particular with the white king being on
B1 this pretty much always comes from
this classical slav do you have any
experience playing these types of
structures I have none yeah more so in
recent years I started dabbling with a
sloth quite a lot as black and with
white I'm obsessed with the bishop here
so I go for these from time to time but
um not extensive uh experience I've got
to say and it seems to be holding up for
black at least a lot of top players are
kind of just
happy to go into this because it gives
you a playable super flexible position
with both colors nothing too forcing
so um yeah I mean if we advance to the
game position I know Mishra has been
playing this with both colors himself I
remember he was playing uh the slab
quite a lot with black so he must know a
thing or two and if we get to the uh
game position perhaps we can yeah
why didn't even play Queen B3 here which
I thought was kind of the norm but
whoops uh today
do something I shouldn't have feels like
I maybe have done something I shouldn't
have but
I'd cut yeah hang on I've done this
before and uh yeah very good
there it is yeah uh
and a very interesting point here of the
queen C2 uh Tabata by goes A5 and after
she takes D5 he just takes with the
Knight and queen
which is interesting
yeah which is quite unusual I think A5
signals very much that we're not going
to be recapturing C to hd5 because
giving up the B5 Square
Precision extent is very unusual but I
would have expected it takes D5 here
being played Without A
much even thought given to it but
instead he went 95 25
and then also traded the Bishops away
okay if you get time to do this at least
it makes some sense what he's been doing
because otherwise you give up the points
on the hand of the bishop pair for free
but yeah okay Castle's Queen side yeah
this Pawn structure is very hard to
evaluate I've got to say
um the one we're getting yeah a lot of a
lot of interesting potential discussion
like inflection points here for instance
for me it would have been absolutely
automatic to play three in this position
for white I mean yeah because I really
do not like the idea of this Pawn
landing on A3 as it happened in the game
because it gives black
uh potential squares to to use against
our King and also
uh if let's say we imagine this ever
becoming an end game I think I would
like this Pawn to be fixed on a light
Square where the bishop can actually
pressure against it in some sort of a
uh you know distant future where Queens
come off uh Mishra instead goes H4 A3 B3
which is still fine you know if black
could in this Mission played Knight B6
before you would be very upset but it
takes them forever like you you can
imagine a root
from B6 to before but it really does
take absolutely forever and we can also
just snap on a six minute Piers there so
it it never actually arrives
no but if we look at the car in position
there is now a queen on that square
uh which is also a bit annoying you have
to uh pay attention to it
but white also made progress on on the
king side there's stuff now being
opened up
yeah it's a pretty black hat to commit
his King to the king side somehow it
would be nice to have it sat on E7 I'm
not sure whether he
I guess King E7 now allows white to
maybe break things open with uh D5 or F5
and each kind of uh weighted Mishra
quite nicely to block things up in the
center wanted to wanted to ask you
what's the latest you ever castled in
your career oh I remember this uh move
37 whoa Queen side against whoa yes that
probably beats my record yeah I was very
proud of this Peter I lit I was
literally waiting uh I could have I mean
I was completely winning and I realized
I could Castle any time and I waited
till the last possible moment
and it wasn't even a good it was good
enough but it wasn't the best move I
just couldn't resist yeah it doesn't
matter like by this point it doesn't
matter at all yeah and uh also it's a
kind of a famous Story by this point but
uh yeah one of my kind of proudest weird
pointless moments of my chest career was
uh and today somehow is the day for this
conversation which is very strange
because I I wasn't specifically steering
it in that direction at all uh but once
again I am
tempted to recall that sequence of four
losses in an RS 99 and the first of
those four losses was a grenfold against
Vichy
in which very famously I
I could still fight like I I was
probably losing the game regardless but
like two or three moves away from my
resignation I felt like the position is
bad enough
that I should go for sort of for
becoming part of History
and I made a move which loses instantly
uh and it was very obviously losing
instantly I knew I was losing uh but in
the final position it gave Vichy the
choice to win the game with like
I don't remember exactly the movement
but it's a high number it's like high
20s maybe early 30s yeah a short castles
check
whoa okay and when I made the move that
loses to short castles check I was I was
faced with a very unpleasant realization
that Rook of one also wins on the spot
so I did something that I've never done
before after I made my move
and then I spoke to my opponent and I
said vicious castle please
he looked at me very strangely but he
did castle and I immediately resigned
but like I wasn't going to ruin my
experience by him playing Rook of one
there like that was that was I was I was
going to make absolutely sure that
castles actually is the move there
a career sucker for punishment
there's no way I was allowing him to
play Rook of one because I was just like
immediately defeat the purpose of all my
previous actions did he tell you
afterwards which one he was intending to
play I can't remember I'm honestly I
think he would have Castle I think we
should also like understands the style
points and things so I think it was
likely because he was going to Castle
anyway but I really wasn't going to
leave that to chance like there's no way
I do appreciate that a player with kind
of artistic Flair um I'm very grateful
to Peter heiner for allowing me once the
kind of box of Pawns on E4 E5 D4 D5 he
played the final move allowed me to get
that box and then resigned that was very
sporting and yeah I I don't understand
players as well who kind of question why
we allow Checkmate I once my opponent
sacrificed the queen I allowed a
Checkmate because it was so beautiful
and afterwards he was like didn't you
see it was mating two why didn't you
resign it's like come on we gotta share
this is a question like that from your
opponent
no that is that is unusual because I
think in general opponents do realize
and also appreciate why you're doing
that normally yeah you occasionally get
questions from from like the the
audience as to because yeah I've also
done this wise once or twice I I think I
once yeah the the my
well the loss that equalized my score
against Magnus I allowed mate on the
board and uh button button 2019. uh
because it was also kind of a
uh funky looking funky looking making
mate and uh uh with two very very far
Advanced pawns but
yeah Magnus wasn't he wasn't uh do
surprise door definitely wasn't annoyed
by it he didn't ask the question no he
did not ask me why I did that he you
know we both smiled and it was yeah it
was a kind of an enjoyable shared moment
anyway uh yeah this is a mess who knows
what this is and on kind of a similar
topic we have a game between Irvin and
Max farmadam which is actually from the
same line but Irvin did play Queen B3
and knows Bishop D2 here but if we
compare this position with this position
I think it's pretty clear that I mean is
doing much uh sort of not I mean Mishra
is doing much better than Irvin because
Mishra has actually started something on
the king side here whereas in Irvine's
case
uh I think it's pretty obvious that most
of the running is being done by black
here
and uh you are just defending quite an
unpleasant position
uh
yeah
you don't really want to play me through
yourself
because this will be a very very
uh important Square for all the black
pieces I like this for for Max
yeah he looks like a dream for black I
think this covers the current situation
and the Challenger so let's go
let's go back up and see what's
happening in the Masters so where do we
go there uh this all of this happened
in the game between Wesley and Vincent
and Vincent did not play Queen C8 yeah
Vincent played Rook d8 straight away
maybe we just forgot that this was
possible we wanted a pin yeah
it's very clever
and weirdly like I thought this might be
kind of very risky because E6 happens
but six we take with the Knight we don't
take
we absolutely Drive the point home that
this is still made in one no not one two
H4 played by
um by Wesley
and I wonder what the Vincent's idea is
to kind of transpose back with Queen C8
but now I am kind of worried about
allowing E6
although fee might be okay yeah maybe
maybe this is just fine I keep on being
very worried I will blunder something
after E6 here yeah and the difference is
with this no longer being made I will be
quite happily taking on a seven so I
think E6 forces if they exceed
unfortunately you have to trade pieces
but I am actually still sort of
interested in this because after Queen
takes
I just don't know which Square to choose
there's two options Queen G4 or queen G6
I think maybe it's actually clever to
combine them I go here and if I try to
provoke Queen E8 and then I drop it back
to G4 and I think I'll win the H6 Pawn
Yeah right
and that's what might be something
unless I play H5 to save it and the chat
says Queen E5 is even stronger yeah okay
yeah this I just didn't see
wow so this could land on the borders
black have any options along this line
do we maybe we don't need to start with
Queen C8 yeah let's let's take a look
here
but I think by by playing Rook d8 we
have sort of locked ourselves ourselves
in a little bit because the bishop is
hanging and
rookie 727 definitely does not look
right Unthinkable yeah to allow the
White Queen in like that
G6 doesn't really help she's six Queen
D3
um
yeah the premise H6 is hanging in yeah
this is always going to be uh going to
be hanging for sure
yeah I was hoping for something uh
clever here but I don't see it really
okay so this doesn't help
black is a bit stuck in that case
we're running out of options
um
yeah I don't see it to be honest G6
Queen D3 maybe we can play we see it
here again but H6 I mean it comes at a
cost now
yeah maybe just a slightly careless move
order yeah but then you have to ask
yourself what would be the massive
massive difference here
like what's the move here if it's not
log d8
[Music]
G6 okay all right now and now Rook d8 I
know but then we
can C4 Maybe
let's see four Quinn and now just H oh
wait
that's the C3 doesn't really help yeah I
don't know if I'm choosing to do
correctly I could go all the way back to
G1 as well even okay for argument's sake
if I give you the ages exponent let's
try to get everything off the board and
argue that my queen side pawns are scary
I think it's a very solid argument we
just need to we need a good move in this
position maybe it's just a 5x4 or maybe
a stop 94 first like 96 yeah we stopped
94 first and then we just start pushing
yeah I can very very easily believe in
this being quite unclear yeah I mean it
still feels like white is the one who
with accuracy can ask some questions but
at least a better version of what we
might get in the game
I'm convincing because now if in the
game position he plays G6 Queen D3 we
get the same thing but without the pawn
on C4
yeah we we conflict in C4 and also we're
actually oh no we're not failing to
but yeah we get we get the same right we
get the same but we get the same
argument but I mean definitely going
down because we like I think C5 C4 being
already on the board yeah it feels like
a useful move in pretty much every
single case here you have some counter
play even even uh in in this version in
this version I'm pretty sure but
and how bad was this line if uh Queen C8
in the game E6
I know we were winning our Pawn back but
was it more than just winning the
Portland back after
um
I mean Bishop takes also exists but it's
very awkward after Queen G6 yeah I like
less I think you can take on C5 at the
minimum maybe oh yeah I'm blanking on
Queen C5 absolutely yeah so Queen G8
Queen E5 let's go 95 I assume Queen E6
choose a square roof actually uh 95 is
coming if I go to the wrong Square uh H7
I guess H7 yeah
this looks very risky fresh it takes H6
Maybe
yeah even that yeah because a GH just
straight up loses Stone
this you luckily for you you still have
Knight F4 but I don't think we're saving
this position definitely not enjoying
this yeah yeah everything is hanging you
never have time to play Bishop D6
because Knight F7 collects
yeah looks like Wesley is in control uh
and you have to find I still feel like
maybe maybe you're right maybe the best
bet by this point is
going for is cringy foreign good
the broken H3 Queen h3o protected now
when there's three specifically to after
Quincy to Simply take only seven is this
worry
could I play something flashy Like
Queenie
or here hmm
clever because there's only one in the
end if you try and take both my pieces
yeah but
you know I don't know how effective this
is I'm activating one piece but I've got
so many other problems
maybe Space six and you still have
everything hanging right so yeah
I don't know this looks this looks risky
for Vincent all of a sudden now
yeah G6 I mean at the very best you're
going into a Net game of corner uh
pulling down so yeah it's not not fun at
all
okay let's uh move on for a bit because
I think we've spoken about this enough
looks like Wesley is now
uh in charge because Vincent uh it feels
like maybe like if you realize G6 or I
guess maybe even D5 is an option this is
where you should go because it's much
more forcing like in this position if
Queen takes C5 happens we go Knight E4 I
don't think we worried so much and uh as
established after mission V6 from d8 the
bishop gets picked up and the resulting
positions are probably just very level
right yeah frequency 5 can be eight this
type of business E5 just goes to G3
black is not going to be better but
black also shouldn't really lose
uh at all
optimistic with the a pawn of some
engines I mean well it just goes B3 and
you never actually yeah uh I think I
think it's just a draw but it's a safe
enough draw for black so the first
possible inaccuracy was not playing the
605 and then we suspect Queen C8 was
actually
weirdly important to start with Minch
rather than Rook Z8 here uh because we
were getting some extra time compared in
very similar positions yeah also because
we missed Rook d8 but uh yeah it just
happens yes uh yeah unfortunately it's
the wrong way but so let's take a look
at some other positions we have this in
the position between uh Ding and Levon
white is
I mean the touch better but the live
will come to B5 I assume and then you
can start exerting a lot of pressure
against the E4 Pawn sorry D4 Pawn set
yeah what's your feeling it feels like
if white was better organized if the
White Rock and A4 was I don't know yeah
or the third rank somewhere then it
should be great attacking chances
because Black's structure is really bad
but yeah I think you're right it might
be five specifically and
unless white is in time I'd still be
slightly worried that uh somehow white
could hold everything together long
enough to get the white knight to C5 but
um
Queen G4 Knight B5
yeah it feels like it's it's not enough
for white right it feels tolerable
tolerable uh
the the scenario that I've described as
a very very hypothetical one in the game
between another back and Prague actually
did materialize after okay four
practical fc8 uh here the engine was
actually suggesting the 5v6 as a
possible Improvement but that wasn't
necessarily winning as such it was just
maybe stronger than what noribbeck did
but what type did do is actually just
win the A6 pawn and they are now playing
this position which
I mean white has four against three but
winning these types of four against
three which are actually
uh quite common in the in the open
Spanish
is extremely difficult
you know uh to such an extent that I
would say probably Joy is joy is
favorite here you think uh if the Queens
came off still quite an easy draw I
think so if this is just such a nice
blockading piece and uh if
I was going to ask if the queens and
Rooks come off
end game with four versus three
there would now do slightly depend on on
Tempe because like if you if you do it
like let me let me find find a way to
to trade here
actually this is a very good example
because if it's black to move I play F6
I'm pretty sure I don't lose yeah
because three against two they're also
quite scary but uh I remember I once had
a conversation with uh with Sasha
grishuk about this topic and he said
that
uh we have this irrational favor or fear
of like night endings being uh being
very dangerous and very easy to misplay
and even three against twos being tricky
specifically when it's not against
Knight
uh but as long as you keep your keep
your wits about you you really aren't
supposed to lose them and I have seen
held one or two uh a lot more comfort
more comfortably than I expected going
in
uh to the end game so I think this is
okay but on the other hand
if white gets to like if you play I
don't know H6 and what goes Knight E4
and then maybe it gets G3 A4 in
those maybe become a bit tricky
yeah but also like why would why would
black ever consent
to those pieces coming off is yeah are
not clear to me you can imagine maybe a
set of Rooks coming off or a set of
Queens but not both yeah not both yeah
exactly
exactly so I think I think not a bit
will press but I also think
prank should generally be holding this
quite comfortably uh an extra extremely
sharp position still on the board in uh
giri erigasi which before was met by H6
which page four can be it takes takes
and uh
this looks very promising for white but
still looks like it shouldn't be very
easy to play
yeah are there any immediate problems
with the diagonal uh the black queen and
white uh and the King if white plays E6
for example I guess we always have
Bishop D6 to block
but yeah it does look terrifying if
black gets one more move and Parks the
King on A7 I'd be very okay with the
Regice position
might just be a matter of uh Tempe so
Bishop G3 or E6 which one do we start
with between yeah some King A8 will be
sort of more or less blitzed out
and for black the setup seems to be like
I think with the King gone from the
diagonal I don't think E6 actually
achieves very much so we're going to try
to put some pressure against the D5 Pawn
so black will try to play Queen 69 B6
I suspect E6 how are you reacting Queen
just c66 I guess yeah
yeah
rookie one yeah yeah important not to
blunder this right but
yeah
as long as
we manage
I guess not B6 or maybe even like F6
trying to put it on e4
because we don't really have to worry
about Knight E5 because it
breaks the connection with the E6 Pawn
yeah those black points are very strong
in the center somehow
holding some important squares
hmm it just visually looks so good for
white butts uh I guess long term yeah
this
you can do something like Rook fg1 I
don't know Queen
56 22 Knight B6 and then maybe try for
A4
level
yeah yeah because A5 might be a very
annoying threat and if you do take on A4
it gives me uh like an immediate access
to exactly the kind of an open file that
I badly want to have access to this
might just be completely unplayable
because you just get mated on the queen
side yeah
yeah very very dangerous for for Argin
yeah I wouldn't like to be in his shoes
right now no I like this I like this
approach as well just kind of locking
things down in the center Knight F3
Bishop G3 and then kind of switching
towards the black king rather than
getting carried away with my E6
suggestion maybe just a bit hasty
uh yeah uh in magnus's game uh Jurgen
actually achieved great progress on uh
on the queen side uh we left it here at
Knight A2 Magnus
chose to include Bishop takes D4 which I
think is a nod towards A5 takes takes
and C3 which maybe he didn't like very
much because
you know it looks beautiful on the king
side you will have some breaks but
um the structure is very locked down and
the green side is becoming maybe a bit
of a
Battleground so he's gone Bishop takes
D4 and then A5 C3
takes takes on D5 this obviously
being the difference he was looking for
um here he is able to
challenge the White Center and
uh in this structure the [ __ ] 1 B7
really isn't doing very much whereas in
the game
it will now be quite active along the
long diagonal
and then you're invent Bishop C4 and B4
very clever very clever yeah opening up
the a file the a pawn and creating a
passer while hiding the bishop away
on B3
and the King side eventually got
completely locked down with H5 H4 Rook
B5 and wait Magnus has just played real
d8
this remains a very sharp end game yeah
I mean white table looks potentially
extremely strong who would you take here
Peter
um
I think black I think in Practical terms
the risks white runs if let's say this
King somehow gets to G3 and then some
sort of you know F5 P5 V4 happens and
the g-pawn Stars becoming vulnerable
yeah are much more because I think the
point is
if you just once again this is not going
to happen just as an illustration
you get it all the way to A7 you ignore
the fact that uh Rook E7 just wins the
phone yeah my larger point is
is just still going to be extremely
difficult to challenge this very simple
setup
in a way that won't allow black to
at the very worst to just give up the
bishop for the opponent A7 and then
collect the entire King side because of
just how much
uh effort you have to expel
to even generate threats on on the queen
side so I think the a pawn scary as it
may look you know it it's not really
running very far as long as this bishop
stays on A8 whereas the the king side
could become vulnerable but all in all
yeah I think it's fine for
I think it's fine for for for yarden but
I think if I had to pick I'm picking
black hair you know and it will come
down to some type of calculation uh
later I I despite the evaluation part
being roughly in the middle I don't see
this being a kind of simple draw for
either no or maybe even a draw at all
I'm trying to work out which pieces we
exchange if we're white I guess we keep
all of the Rooks on the board or at
least yeah we're definitely not taking
only five of our own volition because we
we want to keep the King on F6 so far as
long as possible but yeah King A3 before
would be yeah exactly one way to proceed
or maybe King C3
uh to I don't know if we even want Rook
dito
I don't know what that does yeah I mean
it does black Rush with this plan I
didn't really see anything else
productive for black to do for example
King somewhere King A3 King C3 uh do I
take on B5 and start running in with
King E5 already
[Music]
closer to the
uh queening square but yeah maybe we do
yeah what else what else that's the
question
I guess we could start with King F5
perhaps
start marching already
um
although I'm slightly worried about
something like Rook C7 and um
leaving one
one guy behind to his Doom yeah rookie
seven is
um something that needs constant
constant attention as a kind of
just kind of a small thread that you
know is not that easy to Parry source of
disturbance somehow this is yeah it's
it's a difficult difficult thing to
assess
um
yeah I agree I'm not sure who I would
take to be honest uh I like your
Arguments for taking black there but
yeah at least white has kind of an easy
next move or two can bring the king
forward and then calculate later
yeah we'll see and uh yeah despite this
you know it this might look quiet and
actually maybe even might look somewhat
risk-free for white due to the fact that
you have an outside passer yeah I'm I'm
not at all sure we will not see quite a
lot of
uh excitement in the conclusion of this
game uh or upward versus Maxwell did
actually uh end up featuring the
structure that we were expecting earlier
but via somewhat circuitous
that's not how you pronounce that word
right uh uh around it that way yeah well
yeah very very well done yeah so 94 did
happen uh Parham reacted by playing uh
95 Mr C4 which I guess explains why he
wasn't that worried about 94 because
taking on C4 now uh forces white to lose
more Tempe and actually this this would
have
looked sort of more and more like your
uh like your car all right yeah in a way
you could certainly imagine this coming
from a caracano similar yeah uh so uh
Richard played Rook fd1
for kc8 93 which before
and Parham
started with B5 and then played d65
eventually anyway and this is the
current position
uh the very easy sort of surface comment
here is that B5 is not at all hanging
because it more or less immediately
loses to I mean loses may be a harsh
word but it does feel like it loses yeah
you never ever do this to your own
structure I don't think
uh so a normal move here would be 93 G4
I think
but you have to at least be somewhat
worried about B5 before
more than somewhat I'm very worried
about it yeah so what do you like like
if we don't like 94 and we definitely
don't like uh he's played Rook D4 okay
okay
answers that question for us
this I wanted to say this is a draw for
but it's not quite a draw
how would this be a draw I thought there
isn't the reason I thought this was a
draw for was this ah okay
this doesn't work at all okay okay I
take everything back
yeah it does leave the white Rook on a
slightly odd Square I don't know really
how black can I don't know which move
would I want to try Queen B7 ideally I
want to play but Knight A5 might be
slightly I want to play F5 at some point
and open up the black Bishop but
um the Black Knights currently pins so
not much joy there
are very strange uh strange score for
the Rook but it looks fine
I guess black can always move the bishop
which would be six Bishop C4
maybe if we want to play safe then
Bishop C4 maybe just to cover B5
and if you take I might consider taking
the pawn
well you'll have to but uh yeah I wasn't
sure you're still doing
fine I suppose I could maybe have taken
the Rooks off Albert back seven is
hanging sorry yeah
um yeah I I didn't actually see that I
thought these before was winning
material but it really isn't the bishop
7 is quite strong though
yeah
so yeah removing the light Square
Bishops does feel like it's
kind of a safe approach I don't know if
black can hope for more yeah quite
clearly is setting up the play Rook 81
and to uh simplify and this is something
you need to be somewhat wary of right in
particular now that we've played V7 B5
and created this Target on B5 if you
make some kind of a let's say fairy move
in which I think I we even maybe include
a five and after okay G1 you find
yourself having to allow this massive
trade Let's ignore for a second
membership takes B5 exist and just put
94 on the board
this is I think exactly the kind of an
endgame you don't want to play you would
very much like to have more material to
generate
active counter play with
because this might actually be a little
bit unpleasant yeah that's the thing
with this structure black needs activity
or some dynamism or just to compensate
for
the long term the long-term consequences
of white sequence our majority so yeah I
do feel like now might be one of the
critical moments the more I look at it
the more I quite like Rook D4 just tuck
down on the counter play and slightly
awkward for black it's just a very nice
multi-purpose move it stopped B5 before
which was definitely a major source of
potential counter play for Parham and it
also sets up rook 81 which as we
mentioned is uh I mean an integral part
of what white is trying to achieve uh
which is mass simplifications if we can
get there protects the F4 Bishop as well
which is very happy in a lot of these
tactics yeah and the game we've spoken
quite a bit about earlier but have been
ignoring since is the game between Fabi
and gokash which after Queen C3 and
actually on the break uh I saw our chat
mention that the engine thought the best
move here was Queen A1 which was
apparently even stronger than Queen C3
one potential reason for it uh the
question in chat was can I explain why
and I said well it's side steps all
kinds of potential you know counter play
against the queen on C3 which uh only
one just nothing can challenge it but
also I think very simply we can play
Rook H4 provoke F6 and we can take on C4
with a piece and then with a piece again
so that we don't even have a weakness on
C4 for black to I don't know hope for
end games
yeah in the game after Quincy 397 Fabi
did take to the phone F6 was played
which would be to Rook C5 92
of course Knight E4 was not allowed
there should be 700 cage 45 and I mean
of course white is still winning
white has you know an extra Pawn a safer
King
um not really very much going for good
cash here in terms of active counter
play
but you can sort of see some outlines of
positions
which could be
less completely lost this is not going
to be over optimistic here but we get
just chances but this is the best
position he's had since uh since quite
early on in the game so yeah it's just
going to be too maybe yeah yeah since
Queen B2 for sure
um okay fabi's just played Knight B4
makes some sense do we take this piece
is it just too strong
yeah I think yeah we probably need to
take it away but let's say we talk about
this position yeah and we d8 or
something somehow we imagine that
uh like Queens have come off the board
and we have defended against the
immediate incursion along the G file
maybe got one pair of the Rooks off yeah
and we we have I don't know I can't
really set it up but imagine these these
pieces are gone
let's say this rook and this Rook is
gone and the black king is only six yeah
and we have played Rook A5
you can start seeing how black doesn't
lose right
there is some counter play against
despair maybe you can get the the Knight
26 to block off the G file
and I mean it's still going to be
annoying it's still not going to be any
kind of an immediate quality or anything
like that but you can start seeing the
outlines of positions where our very
nice control over the dark squares might
give us
legitimate drawing chances
um but we're still obviously very very
far away because as long as the Queens
are on the board
you feel like eventually why just
restarts the attack on the king side and
wins
yeah I would just want to play with d8
and try to head towards those types of
positions
um just to start swapping pieces and
move to survive some endgame as you say
um still not easy but I do remember
gokash having a difficult position
against Fabi is black in the Olympiad
for a while for a little while and then
turning things
you never know this game right because
it felt like he came out of the opening
and with with problems but then uh at
some point we had an occasion to kind of
go back and check what the engine was
saying and it looked like
whatever problems he had they were
Maybe
to some degree Optical yeah uh the
position wasn't really all that bad and
then by move 25 ish
it became completely fine and at some
point Fabi had a very clear repetition
he would have gone for
uh but I guess the match wasn't really
standing so well for the American team
and Fabi in general I think playing
board one for the national team with
white yeah he is not the kind of a
person who will
uh gleefully take a repetition against
even a very strong kid but still a kid
you know in a very very important match
you do feel like you're supposed to be
playing on
and like seven months later he was lost
and he was not allowed back into the
game from from that moment onwards yeah
I I don't think this kind of a scenario
is likely to happen in this position
this is a very difficult position this
this these problems are not Optical
black is just a pawn down and
but once your once your opponents
escaped from you in the past from a
difficult position or Fabi would have
been at least confident of his uh
positionality opening in that one once
your opponent escapes you do have this
kind of
thing at the back of your mind this
doubt it's like oh if I can't put them
away here maybe Fabi will think oh I
could have checked mated him I could
have had more this Advantage is still
there clearly but
um you know somehow it does feel like
kukashi stabilized somewhat and
um yeah after rookdale here I'm still
I'm not completely ruling out to come
back or at least a kind of a safe he's
played Queen E6 also looks
very logical
and uh yeah maybe we come back to this
one
a bit later yeah uh people are saying uh
Jordan has played somewhat then
accurately here he's done something we
really were expecting not to happen he
he did voluntarily take only five but he
is I guess he calculated this enough and
he feels that he has come to play
against the F7 Pawn is combined with
something
because you have to wonder what the
movie is after oxidooka fade
you know uh that King is very very quick
that black king yeah because if you if
you have to drop it back to C2 like if
uh if you play I don't know a six King
G3 rookie two
yeah this might be okay or you might
at some point like black goes E5 for
instance A7 F5 yeah E4 notes are running
yeah E4 next move and then you suddenly
find yourself completely incapable of
uh keeping Vegeta Pawn alive and those
just Queen yeah it's not entirely
unlikely that this happens so I'm very
curious there's also some kinds of ways
to
uh go in immediately like G2 of course
is an option but it does allow root
takes F7 followed by Bishop takes C6 if
you go in and this feels like
um
sub-optimal because yeah we've we've
destroyed our own structure and the one
we want to win is really this one like
giving having given up F and E
just winning the pawn of three
first of all this loses to you after
this and the a pawn queens and my arrows
are
famous for being extremely straight uh
that would be the way to
um
actually still E6 yeah you still give up
this one I really don't like giving up
this one because it protects H3 and also
very very importantly in the current
position this piece does
extremely little yeah
very very little
and giving it a very beautiful Square
only six fills
wrong just very simply
yeah I agree it's uh it's hard to
imagine Magnus playing anything other
than Rook Cafe to be honest
I would have thought so as well but if
he wants to win yeah he spent a little
bit too much time on this decision
already which means that there is
something that we're missing is it maybe
a five
with the idea of now going in with
but then we have to
find the refutation of Rook F7 which we
might not have
yeah it will lead to something similar
to what we've discussed maybe even a
better version for white unless there's
some super clever here
King E5 Bishop takes F5 Bishop D5
there's Rook f8 yes
unless he just wants to go behind it
feels a bit fancier right it feels a bit
unnecessary yeah you're not winning this
is black uh ever I wouldn't think so no
I wouldn't think so but did we find
anything for white after Rook f8 because
there's a lot of attention
not so far I was wondering about Rook C5
to just try and stop that from advancing
stop black from uh making progress he
played something very very remarkable
more secret well Bishop D5
uh yeah
yeah I must admit that wasn't even uh
considering this yeah
and which uh I mean it's a very concrete
idea because we we get to
uh we get to the GTO Pawn like in all of
these lines
uh we get to some kind of a position
like like this right a seven or K5
and now we play I guess like King C3
King H3 Rook G7
and uh
do we get any further than here's black
this is the question King H2
what's White's plan just I want to get
it to be six right okay and it's a race
Rook A1 we want to go King B5 yeah if I
can't cross the G file it's really
frustrating uh black this looks like a
draw yeah
which I I don't think it's a risky draw
for black but I also don't know how
we're going to to win this right
G3 takes F3
for instance right but then after King
B6 suddenly Rook A5 is a massive threat
so you actually have to go in with this
and this is I mean quite an obvious draw
here
let's just are we missing anything along
this line Bishop takes D5 does he want
to play uh he takes D5 no I don't think
so
yeah if you take EG then uh in this
position
yeah or Rook G7 I don't know which one
you like better but yeah it feels feels
weaker you know it feels like it was at
least to a draw to be honest
[Music]
the live Whisperer says Bishop D5 must
be a blunder as Rook f8 was 33 better
minus zero dot zero six versus minus
0.08
. such as uh math is unquestionable as
uh young LPR correctly says yeah this is
those are facts
those are those are hard cold facts but
in those types of situations it's just
about kind of a stylistic thing right
it's like Rook f8 gives white a bunch of
choice maybe more more chances to go
wrong this is very linear this is very
direct
and it's unless we're missing something
it's just a matter of counting and yeah
so it seems to be well in time
after King Day stage three maybe G4 but
we like
hang on
so yeah I don't think we I don't think
we get there I think we don't have time
because there's always ah okay G4 FG
King G3
I guess is the point yeah
G55 H3
g67 yeah G7
and we have
to do this this and this oh wow Peter
that is
and we probably take
Queen I wanted to play okay but Queen
yeah I wanted to stop yeah but
unfortunately their screen takes a okay
should also falls to some checks that
yeah so how do we make a draw here
like we can always throw inking before
somewhere yes so the root goes to A1 and
it doesn't change anything what does it
change
can we protect our Pawn now
um
for H3 King B6 H2 Rook H7 came to two
five and if you play H1
it feels like white is yeah if anyone
who's winning this it's not black right
probably it's one of those drawers with
the Rook training yeah they're trying to
get back to the eighth Rank and white
has to allow a repetition to stop so
check
checks oh 27 loses to rokit Sir yeah
sorry okay it draws I mean it doesn't
doesn't lose actually I think Basics are
still a still a comfortable draw yeah uh
so
margins appear to be quite wide actually
because like everything we're watching
appears to be
uh a draw okay let's leave this to uh to
Stew a little bit of the bishop D5 I
think you already did not expect this so
he'll have to have some decisions and
things have developed
over here
uh king8 was played 22 Knight B6 and the
move A4 which I honestly thought was
absolutely automatic the engine
criticized quite harshly like Knight D4
for some reason and then look fd1 and
then I don't know what maybe King H1 F3
which was two eventually or something
but it wasn't very replace it extremely
slowly yeah whereas uh Anish has gone
exactly for the plan that we were naming
uh Arjun took on A4 with a knight
I guess the idea is that after Queen D5
we have Rook d8 yeah
very very important trade of a rook
using the fact that
after the trade taking on C4 is
impossible and then the spawn survives
and it's becoming quite strong so okay
one played and Arjun
is still thinking
I can't fall Anish for not playing a
slower kind of more positional approach
because this looks super scary for black
yeah and it's very human as well to kind
of give yourself
kind of easy player for a simple Target
build up to the time no I like this very
much yeah I think I think I would have
done the same and I would have been
honestly pretty certain I'm doing the
right thing yeah after the game I would
be very surprised that the engine was
suggesting anything else from like it's
one of those situations where
okay
you just shrug and think yeah okay if
this is wrong I don't want to be right
you know
um and there is a threat Rook tc4 is a
huge threat on the board
is a massive threat as well I think yeah
just winning the A6 bomb is check
I wonder whether we can be super clever
and play like Rook Bea to try and get to
B4 if I can because now we're actually
say four doesn't quite work I think I
can take and block with the rook and D1
is and do one is hanging hanging yeah
yeah and uh
I want some well welcome
text chess which I believe is
Thanksgiving uh a Dutch comedian and uh
who I believe was leading the Dutch now
the Dutch coverage during the round
yesterday in in IX Stadium welcome Tex
how are you doing he says surely Reza's
game please
which is
solid committee credentials being shown
right there there's always a few
comedians in the house yeah yeah not
this year unfortunately
okay one no not the previous year either
unless oh that's true no not not any
year seems like yeah it'll be a while
yeah I read about those rumors recently
about alireza going into the fashion
business world
uh promoting what exactly uh I don't
know I just I just read it on uh various
sites actually um multiple
multiple sources saying that that's a
new career direction for him
don't know how viable that was it's not
April Fool's Day as far as I know
uh yeah
okay one looks like Anish is turning the
screw in this one
uh produces articles on his attacking
Styles so I don't know okay I'll do some
more investigating no fair I think I
read it in the Leonard Barden newspaper
column so quite reliable source usually
um
but uh yeah let's get back to this game
and he's looking quite excited
well understandably so and I mean this
is a this is a promising position and
Arjun is also
uh someone down on the clock neither of
them has plenty of time but no yeah
rugby eight actually played yeah you you
correctly predicted the move here I mean
it's just it doesn't seems to Pieces
yeah yeah you won this rookon before a
B3 maybe in some positions and uh as you
correctly pointed out just protecting
against the rookie for Queen D5 thread
very very important we can Chuck any six
yeah he really was actually aware but I
don't know if it does before that just
so that I can take on E6 without having
to worry about my nighttime before
and now I want to start maybe looking
for useful jumps and can I be really
boring and take you and take any effect
is painting right oh wait B4 is also
hanging yeah yeah yeah
that was the
good about that I thought you were
taking it before yeah so you have to
find a square and my sort of I don't
know if it's a larger or a smaller point
but like maybe six but then light shift
to attack so many things at once
that I I really don't think this is
salvageable maybe I play Queen B7 just
now which is why yeah which is why I
think you have to play Queen B7 but even
in this position I think Knight C2 is
potentially very painful C3 C3 and then
I just need to find a good Square
at least I can put my Rook on the fourth
rank now and defend my knight or C4
rookie four maybe a good Square doesn't
exist yet which would be
a regrettable occurrence but let's say
queen E2 or Rook e oh that exists for
some reason I only calculated this and I
thought okay I'll go to dv1 and then
I'll reassess my my options but rookie 4
is just
solves everything in Miles stronger than
the previous option yeah okay uh we can
see on our screen that the engine
disagrees with root B8 and just
generally stops
appears to have to no longer like
origin's position at all
but I'm struggling to
figure out why
yeah
it does feel like it's hanging by a
thread so it's not too surprising I
guess
uh we could also start with Queen C2 E6
we can investigate a bit more
I'm curious yeah there's not that many
more forcing moves Knight D4 do we play
it positionally just uh 94 I was a bit
worried
I'm forcing you to do things that you
might not really hate doing at all
92 is a clear just just getting it I
mean I suspect even this is maybe not
that easy for black to play but you do
have here on trumps like I go Ruby six
and maybe Rook C8 C3 C2 and so on you
know it might cost me my king side but
like if the C Pawn gets to situ I might
not care about the king side anymore
yeah uh so
yeah I'm sure chat will uh throw some
suggestions at us soon but not yet not
yet oh yeah yeah maybe it's just one of
those positions where it's nothing
immediate it's just
a way to keep control somehow and Force
black to contort somehow to defend
um
yeah I'm expecting E6 somehow just yeah
I like I like including the bishop in
the game very much I I I'm not entirely
sure what it does but um
hang on a second no no I mean it's
really regrettable that we don't have
like
do we ever like we never really have a
Tempo here to play like H3 or H4 because
I realized that I have rugby one here
which I originally didn't
ah I didn't see but because of my back
rank I lose to all kinds of things like
Queen D7 is very strong and so on yeah
yeah
so yeah we would like to not have this
issue but we
continue having it yeah the background
questions I guess it's a question of
picking when to play H4 in the current
position maybe you can get away with it
but black people have moves like C3
and finally some some suggestions have
come in uh Jaleel says machine just
takes on D5 and your variation Peter off
the C3 I considered it I just did not at
all think this was clear
like I got here and I thought okay she
do is hanging I still cannot take on A4
because I get mated on the back rank
and uh
I mean like King F1 wins or something or
H4 or something but like
yeah from afar it's so hard yeah I'd be
I'd be very reluctant to go for this
because if we are wrong about this
position we are very wrong also
we're okay I guess rookie 4 we actually
control enough with white to be able to
do this because we
we control the very important day one
square here and little sometimes flavor
of takes C3 is all um yeah okay so we're
just in time to to collect yeah
yeah King F1 was so with small age but
super complicated play which is what
just 24 chats has like Ruby two actually
King F1 Rook C2 okay like okay E7 E7 E7
here wins okay then I can sort of
believe it but I also want to say
actually does it win in that final
position because there was Rook C1 check
for C1 C1 rookie one
who knows yeah maybe we've lost this
with white I mean not lost but like
we're in trouble maybe because he's
Seven Falls
but I mean this is the kind of thing
that Anisha will be calculating and uh
maybe struggling to draw conclusions
just like we are yeah no but this is
exactly the point that like if if you
give me
this position
already the one after yeah where is it
this one like if you show me this
position I will probably play King of
fun in a practical game because I will
just rule out everything else and yeah
in particular if you have some time like
not maybe on 30 seconds but on 15
minutes I
back even myself to find decent moves in
this position but to go specifically for
this from here
yeah and to believe yourself to to
actually kind of correctly assess that
this is your best
is very very difficult yeah
when you're trying to attack feels yeah
there are so many options yeah
in the meantime Chad told us that uh 5V
is now just straight up winning this is
the position
yeah it looks like maybe even 27 check
very very simply just you know
simplifying into an absolutely winning
end game because take Stakes you you
can't really give up on H7 but if you
play King G8 you're also you know your
your life expectancy here is not
has to be very low the bishop must get
in somehow yeah the just Bishop G3 F5
from five five root 5v4 there he falls
yeah maybe there's three maybe from this
route
3 and 95 and then maybe F7 or something
yeah yeah looks looks horrendous how did
we get here we left it uh yeah
uh and uh gift played Rook A5 here which
I think is understandable because you do
feel like you need to generate at least
some counter play and then Fabi went in
with a G4 and H6 and after 96 he is
still thinking I don't think Windows 7
is necessarily even the only move maybe
there's something three looks three
looks also very very tasty right
yeah I guess black can play
genius
somehow because Queen before we have
Rook C5 but I mean all of this looks
frankly looks kind of lost yeah even
even this position like I go Rook D5 if
you go Rook fc8 I spent one Temple of G3
just to make sure nothing is hanging and
then I will put the bishop on D5 and
yeah this is just so surely yeah okay I
do wonder whether good catch missed the
trick just getting pieces off the board
when you play Queen E6 it felt a bit
kind of a bit no like a nothing move uh
I would have expected Rook d8 if at
least if you get Rooks off the board
long-term chances of holding yeah I
thought so as well yeah I thought uh
trying to simplify a little bit uh
should be it should be quite good yeah
and uh
excuse me flicking flicking in c45 here
apparently is also very very strong just
really takes Rook take some now we go 27
check the point being in this position
we have
Rook C4 and
um yeah but this this comes with uh I've
been reading a little bit uh warning
like this is you're not talking to me
you're talking so Superior braid over
there silicon stamped up yeah yeah the
superior brain does this and says plus
five so yeah yeah somehow I sensed that
this was yeah like Beyond human
capabilities no I think I considered C5
I just didn't realize that the change
that it wants is specifically to have
access not even to Bishop C4 straight
away but this this rooksi formula is
just very very
that is painful to face and I guess
nomination after after this we give a
check and now we take on C5
and uh yeah these types of positions
with Bishop C4 check coming in I just
like utterly utterly lost this Pawn on
H6 the the alpha zero Pawn on H6 you
know is is going to be the decisive
Factor now and Fabi has four minutes
but this is move ah actually this is 29
so he does have to make a decision it's
a very good position for him but he does
have to make a decision
yeah I think so just briefly to update
the viewers Jordan played all of this
has already moved 42 and all of this has
been played onto the board and we assume
both King H2 and G4
are draws
and also interestingly
this is the position in anisha's game
okay so we're doing some decent guessing
could be headed in that direction with
Queen takes D5 this whole variation that
would be
crazy if it does uh yeah okay
the only move that does anything at all
oh I will now switch it off but I was
kind of curious
uh so the line there uh it's not cese so
I don't know how correct it is uh the
point apparently
is that in this position we have Rook F4
let's see from afar yeah and then we've
also taken care of Rook C1 checks and
after Bishop H4 we are somehow in time I
just need to remember exactly how to do
but I think we just actually we just go
no no we include the check we include
the check here
we take and we play seven I think
and we end up we end up here
but I'm not sure if we end up winning or
not
good luck finding this over the board oh
yeah might you do already played but as
I said the big issue is to just go for
this entire line yeah but once let's say
you get here you realize you realize C3
C4 is a massive threat you would
actually much rather not have Knight on
D4 hanging so you do play Knight C4
Knight C2 for Arjun it feels like there
is currently no choice whatsoever
because this is hanging and if it goes
somewhere you just drop the Knight on A4
so you you can't really help butt play
C3 I I guess this is the turning point
because maybe Anish convinces himself
that he can play it on Queen G3 or
some kind of a quiet move here which is
not when takes D5 yeah uh I don't think
he ever plays this because he will not
land the rookie 4 as I did but
I think you you can sell yourself on the
idea of playing Queen D3 waiting for
black to play it on Rook C4 and then
playing kind of The Rook DB1 and just
continuing
this I can't imagine
but I can also Imagine him just taking
on D5 and actually finding much of the
line
that I just quoted simply because you
just take it move by move you don't
calculate it yeah you don't calculate it
here you don't even attempt to calculate
it here
you just decide that you're taking on
five after B2
you consider your options you find king
of fun out of necessity and it goes like
that it continues going like that move
by move by mode wow Peter Fabi has
played this whole line with C5 so classy
I'm gonna say just simplifying into a
dominant end game rather than cling onto
the extra Pawn
yeah I'm guessing Rook grade seven also
wins gear but I think rookie Rook C4 is
just such a classy move to to make just
make sure that you trade off the one
somewhat good piece that black has here
right yeah
you allow Rook C1 and maybe Rook H1 and
yeah buttons Rook d8 sometimes it's
slightly annoying
um at least black can hope to survive
for a bit longer yeah probably still
lost but
yeah I think having gotten here you you
do generally find Rook C4 yeah I mean
the one difficult thing is to assess
Rook F7 but I think it's very accessible
it's uh it's not going to give too much
trouble to a player of obvious caliber
too
to figure out he is pretty much
completely winning in those types of
positions yeah and he hasn't okay wow uh
maybe it's the wrong situation that he
is proving that he is actually a human
who knew and I'm still looking promising
still looking very nice you know
and he has gone with C1 Rook H1 he's
eliminating
Alpha zero uh Soldier there on H6 yeah
but we just uh
I assume we plant the second one on the
seventh and we still win right we just
go Rook gc4 you know okay six Rock C7
and inside The Rook C4 B4 maybe I'm not
sure yeah we could actually go after the
B6 spawn as well but
I like just you know doing this pushing
the bishop on D5 putting the King on it
too and then winning sort of Any Which
Way like it's it's going to be
because despite equal material black is
just like utterly helpless against just
most of our plans yeah even King C3 can
be forced up in that direction
yeah looking good yeah
decision to finish
whoa oh okay this has changed yeah and
he has actually done exactly what we are
uh suggesting he does so after H4 he was
I mean he definitely is aware enough to
figure out things he's gone G6 Queen H3
has not happened there was I guess some
reason for
uh for not going in that direction that
they both agreed on Wesley played Queen
G3 and then they went for
this A5 B3 and after B3 Vincent found a
very very cute way to generate immediate
counter play might be fightful by Knight
A3
that's not uh immediately obvious maybe
Wednesday but also H4 is hanging right
so he's attacking C2 and you will
probably want to play Knight E1 but then
we just take on H4 and we claim that we
are like just maybe better because we
have equal material and threads so
Wesley played C4 A4 and now G3
finally covering the H4 square and
obviously intending this
you know this is a weird standoff
between the nights I guess white just
wants to March the king to D3 in order
to free up the Knight and take on B3
yeah you might actually be somewhat
threatening 92 as is yeah
Bishop C7 I think is a way to try and
you know maintain this weird
equilibrium
is
strong
I guess the question is does black have
anything else the natives
I don't see it yeah I don't see it and
now maybe we do this but after F4 we
still haven't really won
any of those forms
yeah it's close but Bishop C7 Bishop B2
there we can't quite take on C4 plus
just uh it's interesting that the engine
thinks this is equal so we're
seems like we're missing something
because the positions we just discussed
they don't didn't look equal could it be
something to do with uh I don't know
what move order but
ab392 F6 just to try and open things
as quickly as possible
um
assuming Bishop B2 but
just guessing here
1206 doesn't help there's a number of
questions here right because
uh first off how confident are we this
is a draw
not fully but honestly this might be
just completely fine for Blake because I
have even maybe this option
okay and because uh like this is going
to be a very strong Knight on C4 here
King F1 D3 system yeah D3 King U1 Knight
C4 and I mean we will definitely win at
least like white also has people H5 only
three King G1
I'm guessing this ends up being a draw
um
upsettingly for all of us yeah because I
I can't figure out a way for black to
win more than the stupid Bishop for both
of these
and then white will
very easily trade the final one with H5
yeah this is still a mess what's
the the clock situation the clock
situation is five against fifteen four
seven slash eight moves whose position
would you say is easier to play here it
feels like the onus is on black at least
the next few moves but
I think I think for white many of the
few future moves like in the media
future moves will be
more or less forced
like I don't know it's it's very
complicated
yeah yeah in the meantime Anish did not
play King of fall and you did find Queen
takes D5 but he did not play
uh King F1
and when H4 feels more natural somehow
especially if you don't spot this Rook
F4 or that Rook check kind of uh
sequence that we were talking about so
let's check the most obvious thing what
happens if we do this and take and is
yes this is not the Perpetual if you go
in this direction but I but I guess you
like if you continue going this way you
lose yeah
so this would be a draw so it's at least
a draw right because I I guess it's a
joy if you go if you go here
like you you probably should not be
crossing the f file at all well there's
like it feels like if you do this you're
really kind of damaging fate
in terms of some kind of C3 C2 work C4
shenanigan Ray and now I don't know some
kind of thing just for a community
yeah like this for instance and I don't
know how happy you are to be suddenly
calculating this in like 30 seconds or
whatever like they have more time but if
you turn the other way uh Peter maybe
there was some check mating patterns
like uh I don't know whether I start
with rookie two or check and rookie that
is actually I thought I was okay with
the APA but the other one gives me
ah
huh this is oh okay this means that that
E7 is
for chief four maybe not the winning of
them so you go Rook G4
I guess we play still safe at least
[Music]
um
at least his wife's asking the questions
here some background problems for black
this time
repeat two East no I lost this seven
right and then we didn't check yeah and
this is hang on is this
this is also a queen right
and it's just to draw the end
this is pretty takes G7
we'll see somehow
well I mean black still has to make it
because I think we lose the H6 Pawn
right I have to go here and oh no we
don't lose the H6 Pawn because there's
Rook C6 so you can flicked in a check
Rook G6 before yeah weird differently
yes or Ruby six yeah we cannot go back
because we actually do get mated so we
have to go forward yeah now we go Rook
C8 and we get in this position yeah
I was trying to see if I could win the
A6 spawn somehow but I'm not sure that
was ever possible yeah and this is who
knows what this is I'm giving up
the chat yeah chat can count for us
yeah uh let's briefly because it feels
like many of these games are about to be
uh just mathematically decided let's
briefly check in with the with the
challenges because uh people are saying
some people have very nice finishes uh
Irvin is suddenly I guess winning I
wanna I wanna play Queen G5 but it
doesn't work so
uh
it doesn't work right now Queen f
no I'm a bit scared of nice yeah because
I I saw a mentioned in chat of Irvin
having a very nice win here maybe it's
Queen C1 first
and Rook takes C1
or it takes C1 Queen oh yeah the queen
can't get back
yeah
um is just very very cute yeah we also
created this thread yeah we also created
this thread and we're moving The Rook
away from the good squares
so yeah looks like Queen C1 yeah this is
actually a very peculiar setup right
where we're threatening this but also
wherever the queen goes we yeah the
other we've made
you've made from there that's beautiful
if that it is it is a very very like if
he finds this he will be a a very happy
I feel like a superstar like you can do
this and here are somewhat precisely you
lose the bishop Basics I think the
simplest and then just see it next move
and this is only one check because we
control everything very very nice
uh what about KH
's seven in that last position oh sorry
yeah uh
seven yeah I obviously blundered that
yeah this is not very clear so Knight C3
um takes Queen d8's
Hmm this feels winning it does
feels winning somehow but anyway I had
time to lock the box with Richie's uh
Bishop G6 sometimes I'll show you yeah
let's just do this and win slower and we
don't need to win I mean and then just
Rook C1 Rook H1 actually yeah this is
very very clear cut yeah actually Bishop
G6 looks nice meanwhile we did see on
the camera there that kukesh has
resigned
um maybe we can just show the end of
that game
yeah so Fabi played after okay she won
5B as you suggested correctly played
Rook before takes B6 and then rook bb7
and yeah I mean this just does seem you
know utterly hopeless you never generate
any activity this Rook is tied to the
production of the H7 Pawn this Rook is
tied to the back Rank and Y just pushes
I don't think it's in any way premature
at all throw in the towel here so yeah
the
sermon continues going very poorly for
brukesh uh but he's I think his first
couple of losses were against people
just playing extremely well against him
he lost the ding and he also lost to
particular Stone
it's been a long time already
yeah to uh Geary oh yeah
very very nice uh in
in the supposedly quiet ragosan but
today this feels somewhat self-inflicted
because uh
another goes in but just yeah another
question but opening disaster yeah felt
like he chose this line himself like he
played all of this 97 B6 and uh
uh English Basics all of this was played
pretty quickly and Rook c85 was kind of
glitched out and then after Queen B2 you
you know you suddenly find yourself in a
potentially just a straight up lost
position by move 14 having not really
done very much yourself and having not
really forced white to do too many
outlandish things so today does feel
like he's maybe
finally has an occasion to
uh feel unhealthy about his own play
because the previous two losses like he
just got
got caught in the opening by by Gary
like he ran into a very very dangerous
new idea and couldn't couldn't handle it
and against ding uh ninja style played
him from a very sort of a difficult
strategic complicated strategic position
which does happen
uh Richard Drew in the meantime yeah
this position uh we left it somewhere
here and uh yeah black did
well equalize here reasonably
comfortably
yeah like things continued yeah things
continue disappearing and yeah not very
much left to play here so they agree to
draw Ian magnus's game Magnus play G4 FG
and we we have established how this is a
draw I think the draw is half the king
G3 you just run up with the King to G6
the B6
and uh you are in time to start running
both via passers
uh so black has to take some kind of a
draw at some point yeah it's a one type
per game but yeah easy calculation for
these guys yeah
uh meanwhile in the challengers yeah
Elena Roberts lost today to day really
has not been a particularly good day for
her
uh seems like she played once again she
played a very uh ambitious very
principled line of the Cairo which
is extremely committal because by move
12 you will be like you are either going
to be much better at some point or
you're going to be strategically lost
uh having done this to your structure
and uh today was clearly the case for
being strategically lost
um
Jager special is
a bit better from that Greenfield end
game but this is a yeah one of those
cases where
there's a spawn on D6 supported by the
bishop 25 supported by the rookon C6
but it's unclear how much progress you
can make
yeah with the white Rook yeah it's
difficult to it's difficult to generate
threats even let's say you get the king
to B3 you still aren't generating
threats
um looks like shindarov is completely
winning against
uh what why is why does it say equal on
my screen it's The Rook
no there it's not trapped maybe Queen E3
Queen G5 check what on Earth like what
I've like I refused maybe there's a full
straw Peter Queen E3 yeah 23 to give a
church
like oh maybe even 93.93 yeah yeah and
this is actually coming back to just how
safe
I remember in one of the the books I
read when I was a kid
I think there was a quote by I want to
say
Solomon floor
about
looking on H2 specifically behind this
Pawn structure
feeling like it's uh like in a very warm
bed
covered by
like five duvets or something I can't
remember the exact description but it
was a very kind of a picturesque
description of being very very cozy
living in this Palace yeah and uh
King safety is just so important like
this one is completely safe and this one
is very very
uncovered so white has a lot of counter
play but yeah my my initial reaction
when I saw this
was
Queen black is a PornHub there's a
protected Pastor only four
like we know what this is
but apparently we don't
yeah it's miracles do happen material
isn't always everything uh Vladimir
ivich
is
still winning although maybe not as
cleanly as we would have expected but
here's a piece up now so looks plenty
good enough
uh again study Bond and Irvin didn't
find Queen C1 but Rook C1 really isn't
any wars
yeah it's just less flashy but still
does the same job it's almost the same
idea just yeah coming up your queen yeah
just just without the giving up of the
queen yeah I mean the difference is
let's say after a cafe we are not
threatening rukesh one yet which we
would have done in the other one like we
would we would have already won the game
with Rook H1 here but we can generate
the same threat after I guess like
something like hg3 and then Queen G2 and
like the threat will be generated and
black will not have a good reply to it
so yeah if Erin will still win our uh
hanging Pawn position in the game
between the leader and Thomas Perez had
ended in a draw
so this I think concludes the current
situation in
uh in the challenges let's go back up
yeah it looks like Vincent's has gone
astray
um yeah this uh it just does not look
right yeah how did this happen G3 he
went Knight B1
which is a very very odd thing to do
don't really see what the night's doing
there you do Force B takes A4 you force
plus B Pawn but you could have two past
three pawns if you take on uh B3 right
now
I think maybe that line that we showed
was Critical with black trying to break
out with F6 and it comes down to a race
maybe but
it looked like yeah yeah and uh
I did check Bishop C7 is somewhat
playable but what it likes is just
straight up your suggestion of a B92 F6
I'm also super curious about E6
but enough
I'm just getting a fate and King
oh yeah we can we can we're probably in
time to do that right king of Fate like
Knight B3 and Knight C4 Knight C5 King
seven and Bishop yeah yeah and this
probably doesn't happen quickly enough
I would assume like G4 Bishop B6 93
B3 H5 yeah the king is just sorry I
think it's the king is higher yeah we
don't even need to use the light pieces
yeah we might be better now you probably
are better actually
yeah
[Music]
so maybe one is maybe one is a bit of an
odd one because you just left white with
an additional passer that wasn't on the
board a moment ago and uh Knights are
famously very very bored
covering those passers I guess maybe
what he meant was I am not threatening
Bishop C3 and B2 but Wesley has played
[ __ ] P2
sorry Bishop beatso
and now
like your choices are they all look
kinda hopeless he loves putting his
Bishops on A5 Vincent he did it
yesterday against Lebon
um the bishop was on A5 for a long time
but yeah Bishop C3 you're just always
Bishop C3 and it actually sets up a very
nice trap because okay what you would
like to do here with white I think is to
go A5
which I think 94 94.
I think this is gone yeah like this is
an actual Queen with Czech
uh but you can play 92 first I'm pretty
sure b2a5 is
hang on how clear is this probably very
clear right we take take we don't even
need to play six we can start working
it's a minimum we gotta make sure that
it doesn't happen yeah
and even if the apron doesn't become a
queen after something like I think we
just win by force actually yeah uh
because we're threatening King D3 and
then A6 so you have to do this
and then I just win this Knight I think
she took him three I know you could you
could have gone
uh you could have gone eight two three
two yeah but but then
actually I think this is much cleaner
come to think of it
because 92 doesn't stop the pawn and if
you go in this direction you actually
have no way to ah so something like this
is this is actually a queen again yeah
uh which means that you just cannot play
Bishop C3
white is currently maybe not threatening
King E2 very much because then Bishop C3
oh maybe they're not who we are oh
they're still we are
so let's say we go king of Fate King E2
yeah I think actually maybe even even
the larger problem is like before and
continue waiting and just remind you
that there is going to be
uh Ambassador on this side as well but
also maybe King U2 is also winning right
uh although King E2 Bishop C3 the a pawn
is hanging
I mean I suspect this is still winning
is my point
okay not be too check Maybe
yeah but I have so many of them I can
give you a two and then go just get
around go around yeah
we still win even this but there might
be cleaner ways
before probably not a mistake I'm also
wondering about Knight C3 for black in
the current position very similar but uh
at least
going for a pawn
but you
lose to this right
ah okay and English to this
it's so kind of unfortunate because it
does feel like you're always like one
tempo away from actually before I can
win the C4 Pawn Maybe
six next move
yeah
at least it's a position you can play on
a bit and probably still losing yeah I
think this structure is a little bit too
strong and you will not end up saving it
but you're absolutely right this might
be a choice
you are forced to make in the meantime
there is a question in chat why why does
Gary look so annoyed this is his
position
after H4 uh and Bishop takes F2 he
didn't even play Bishop takes F2 he
played King H2
uh Rook D2 is a very clever move here by
Arjun
uh activating his own Rook stopping all
kinds of his seven Rook d8 threads
and pretty much forcing I think I needed
to do what he's done which is
this very far sequence black still has
to show I think
some slide care
because if you do this like is this draw
or no we have to count this one out
because this occasionally this position
is lost
well it does have G3 and G4 here so I
think it's G3
I don't know H5 now is it wrong this is
just withdrawal okay so you have to go
G4 but then I'm thinking of six makes a
row and king oh I can't count here King
G8
uh
uh and G6
is the worst
yeah
oh but we can just chill right we can
just pass this is a this is a three-fold
one of the weirdest uh three fours so
anyway seven like how clear is
something like this
King D6
King H5 King E6 and is this a fortress
Ken White
I'm guessing something like Rook D4 just
holds here yeah
although like in a practical game I
would very much like not to have rookie
two check yeah I could keep talking D6
and it does seem once again that we're
kind of
really uh struggling hinging everything
on one temp or somewhere like the
existence of G30 G4 check
mm-hmm
is there a way not to calculate any of
this at all like is there a way to maybe
just go rookie 5 and claim that
thou shall not pass yeah at some point
where it has to activate the record in a
way you don't have two over K2
and try to pass try to get the white
work around so Rook d8 I guess maybe oh
yeah maybe even more clever with d8
it can black create enough counter play
before Rupert G8 happens
hmm I
G6 also exists like us trying to stand
with shield with g656 we could actually
do it like Chad suggests doing it
immediately which may be
uh the simplest I was a bit worried
about H5
yeah but then maybe we just go rookie
for rookie six and like how how bad can
this be honestly really how bad can this
be
and by this point we'll be past me 40 so
Arjun will have
plenty of time to work out I think we
already are yeah current position has
moved forwarded soon okay 42 years
already
because G6 you definitely don't want to
play if you've got 30 seconds left oh
yeah yeah this is not a decision you
want to make on on very very low time uh
so we have this uh the entire line that
we were talking about happened in
Wesley's game and Wesley says I would
like to have a bishop against Knight
here
also logical and you would have to give
it give it to me because otherwise the
pawn doesn't fall so we take take the
bishop price system goes here this looks
lost and it's nice that the h-pawn
promotes yeah oh yeah this looks lost
which is the three or four G4 and we
start pushing and we can also agree to
like we can always keep the bishop on C3
if it gets attacked from A4 for instance
because the setup on the king side is
unchallengeable yeah
[Music]
this looks lost all right
uh in notibex game against Prague this
is the position that they are now
discussing
uh so we left it somewhere here probably
2c2
you can see one Queen C4 and the Queens
eventually did come off and he I think
very cleverly very quickly played G6 G5
to
make sure that this and this never get
connected
and uh
yeah even if he is not making any kind
of a force draw here the position is
very solid
yeah it's hard to imagine I mean with
that rock on E6 but anything bad ever
goes uh goes down the H Pawn maybe if
the Rooks come off now
it should still be a draw of course but
White's H Pawn could be annoying as a
distraction
yeah but we obviously are probably so
active that we never ever traded yeah he
just played Rook a four and now he is I
think very happily going to start
threatening to give 100 checks yeah
um
I think this one uh yeah yeah I think he
holds this one uh Jordan has played King
before and magnus's thinking
not entirely sure what about like what
what would be the difference between
Rook A1 and Rook A2
we're definitely not playing Rook A6 and
uh like just on General grounds you
pretty much always play rookie one
because Rook A2
feels weird not have a threat of H1
let's say when the pawn gets to H2 and
The Rook is on H7 uh but it's all very
very similar the draw that we were
describing is basically
white is just in time to get here
and uh
uh
you just don't have very much
how do we even how did we even win that
Rook
there was a we somehow won that Rook
very good question
I'm trying to recreate this too of
course yeah
G5 H1 Rook H1 King H1 G6 and black needs
to be well he's gone King what is that
Rook a six
was he afraid of something specific
ah was he afraid of maybe Rook C7 if
he'd gone the other way ah
c33 okay three
I mean this is very counterintuitive it
feels like there must be a way to draw
here
what's this question sure why it's
clever yeah surely minimum you should be
able to take 197 and take on G4 I can't
yeah that that should be a draw but
maybe but although actually this that's
actually pretty close if we if we have
to discuss this actually the presence of
the E6 Pawn means I can't still make
myself sometimes which
it's a bit annoying potentially
yeah
why is that E6 Pawn on the board King H1
would have been a nice
and without the pollen issues this is
winning
by very simply playing Rook G8 here you
can just play Rook G8 and it's a stale
uh it's a it's a Twang and the light
gets picked up but with the ball on E6
it goes E5 before so I don't know I
think it's still winning Pizza I had
pretty much the exact same end game with
the Olympiad white ghost uh Rook G2
check instead of Rook G8 maybe you
always threaten Checkmate and then you
pick up the pawn
oh you just take you just take here yeah
we can just take here
yeah and after King G1 we find a way
like okay I guess yeah exactly it's
gonna be six one sooner or later yep
yep
so understandable that he didn't want to
engage with this like yeah Rook C7 is
67 is devilish
and the threats continue maybe King
takes G4 no I wonder if we can go King
jutu though
H3
this still looks like a draw to be
honest G6 uh two
seven yeah can I keep okay yeah we we do
not want to be playing this position
with work
I just wonder we're never winning G4
um just to get out of 303
oh wait you go the other way it's not a
chicken then you have to go either here
or here yeah I will I will get what I
want we keep losing
November says among this is for you know
stop the Press Magnus good at chess he
spots things that most of you guys did
yeah news flash button is good at chess
yeah
let's let's tweet about it now yeah yeah
okay six I guess we've got to count
again though because white gets an extra
Tempo in the uh no black is I think
I think we can go okay one simply I
think we hold this way
and King B6
of just h3h
and then we start checking and yeah we
just give checks yeah like if we want to
draw we always have a draw here by just
check check and
Emerald takes A7 is a threat so no we're
not losing yeah as long as we don't
blunder exactly what we have avoided
blundering just just this moment I think
we're always we're always fine yeah
yeah he really does see these little
details it'll be so easy to just uh play
Rook A1 on autopilot Rook C7 happens and
then Panic yeah and uh chat says
obviously first engine light is Rook
takes A7 so I guess we've miscalculated
something there how is what how why or
it takes a
seven take take
really
H3
[Music]
King
of three maybe but it doesn't show the
Rook H7 King G2 King E2 ah wait what
hello
are we being trolled here
or are we missing something apparently
not but
something super obvious
all right let's see it I've got to say
unless it's one of those no it's not one
of those weird situations where you can
just kind of just wait and push the
e-born later
three rookies seven King James two h two
yeah I'm confused Peter I've got to say
we need help from this yeah I'm I'm I'm
yeah I'm just going to because obviously
this is
people quoting table bases at us
so I'm just gonna ask sort of case seven
rookie seven King G4
uh loses then there's no reason any
human would calculate this of course
I think Magnus has found it much far
away
all right reveal to me what are we
missing King F3 here
I don't understand
ah
there's a detail I feel I feel very
annoyed
okay uh
Rook H7 uh yeah no we don't go King F3
okay uh we go H2 Rook H7 King G3
King E3 and we go E5
yeah and uh we are not giving up the
Double C in the corner yeah this is
I feel very annoyed by this
this is just so unfair yeah like it
hinges on this like it hinges on the
fact that in this position well not not
Queen obviously uh in this position we
have a four check
and we will be able I guess to
extricate the name Jackson Decay the
night somehow even though like even this
doesn't seem obvious to me at all
because Knight G3 we have to
like we have to go for this and like
yeah I know it's supposed to be a draw
but like my my knees would be shaking so
much in like 24 and then you get
disconnected and yeah the Knight gets
separated from the King and like oh
yeah this is never gonna happen this is
not human stuff
wow yeah so E5 I'm surprised I mean I we
say top computer line but
um yeah of course there must be a bunch
of moves which say 0.0 uh Rook A6 unless
we've missed something seems to be doing
the central just far easier far simpler
yeah I think uh not getting involved
with this like Rook A6 I think stops all
of the shenanigans because now Rook C7
doesn't actually create a single thread
because we can very very easily take
force you to do all of this and then
compared to the other position we still
have root takes A7 with a very immediate
draw because the white king is not only
do it's still on before uh and if you
force game before if you go to A1 now
now white will not be hang on rupee 7
here
I guess now we go exchange to yeah yeah
and we're not ever touching the G4 Pawn
so it's not to run into this and this is
uh clearly quick enough
yeah break a lot of stuff
uh so we're expecting a draw in this
game the Geary game one game we haven't
checked in in a while is ding against uh
Iranian yeah I keep on expecting this to
sort of disappear off our screens
because some kind of repetition gets
found but as a matter of fact it just
became very sharp instead we've just
made new 40. yeah so some shuffling
ensued more shuffling and like every
single time this happens you feel like
if if left plays kind of six gear Rooker
4 might happen again because we've we've
had this yeah so but Lev avoids it
and uh avoids it
I know now Jing avoids it doesn't play
Rook G4 anymore
and uh yeah the current position zinc
has actually committed with uh
all of this and Knight C5 the 1.85
Knight takes D7 on the board I assume it
takes a four yeah I guess the Knight
goes
so maybe an argument for C5 but E5 looks
like such a good Square well
until you get out of the mind yeah until
you get immediately undermine and you
have to solve more
immediate questions but it's 96 is a
movement of threeism of Roxy oh can you
try to go for checkmate uh is there a
Checkmate C8
and I want to close you in with Note G6
but oof
okay this must this feels study like
yeah seven you can make it so you can
include Queen C2 G3 but I don't know
what that does yeah
so let's start with Knight F7 you can
also go Queen C7 Queen d8 sometimes
oh
oh wait the rook's honey
yeah I was going to be very proud of my
Rook H1 idea but uh but I don't have to
be very very proud of this yeah it's a
knight of seven another seven
cheese somewhere six I guess
Queen C7 well it's it's just super sharp
Rook D7 is a move 97 is a move
on the tick on F4 I don't know if that's
mating or not
maybe not
wow so
this could be relevant I mean we don't
need to go into too much detail yeah but
it could be relevant if uh they also
Rook H5 apparently which which
apparently is zeros if I understand
which position correctly but
chat are just spoiling all that yeah
Chatters chat is like ruining ruining
all the enjoyment for us by
saying completely outrageous things yeah
I'd be terrified as black still here
especially if I have to play with like
G6 or G5 but
work H5 I guess they're sympathize okay
uh not not here uh
ah okay so maybe we can show that and it
takes uh where Knight takes C8 ah just
just here
it feels almost suicidal to allow my G6
but rotates yeah but apparently machine
says not more than a Perpetual do not
fret
amazing amazing it looks like Checkmate
was locked on but no no no
uh all right so this is move 41 which is
I think the the reason for the pause
because difficult to imagine left going
going here you have already played yeah
so I guess we are done with the time
travel everywhere so let's do a brief
Roundup of what we have we have this
really messy position being blitzes out
95 here uh C5 is not forced you can
I think there's actually a decent
argument for Knight C6
unless 96 is very strong we need two is
also a move you maybe have to consider
in some positions looks like black
should not really be doing all that
poorly I actually quite Like Queenie so
unless I can take on C7 and yeah right
like this has to be enough for a
question uh maybe not yeah because you
have Queen E1 there
[Music]
but honestly even their position feels
yeah like Queen takes B3 here and and
then I started giving checks again yeah
it still feels like enough cancer for
sure yeah so a mess here uh we assume
this is winning for
for Wesley because it's just very
difficult to handle all the threats
which will be
forthcoming very very soon like can you
do a 4g4 F5 H5
uh and the Knight really will struggle
to get to any Square which is
of any relevance
yeah
um this we assume is a draw
you still probably can ask some
questions but
they shouldn't be very difficult
questions that's precise calculation
from arigati to judge he can play Rook
D7 allow the king of porno game which we
yep I had to check for a while yeah this
one I mean absolutely no reason for
another back to offer a draw but
should still be a draw eventually yep
I'm very much wondering if you should
just play G5 G4 somewhere
because currently if you start giving
checks the king hides itself quite well
somewhere around the 585 squares
let's say okay for checking H5 I think
we've kind of ruined that position quite
a bit because it will be supported by
another fun Knight F5 and then the Rook
will come in and challenging this guy
will be actually surprisingly difficult
but flicking in G5 G4 if you now play H4
now I can do the same I think without
much in E3
Knight C5 which is also a very concrete
way of dealing with things creating both
this and this thread
yeah I think I think he he holds this
because neither five is pretty much
always just
just a very ignorable ignorable check uh
yeah this will be a draw momentarily
because magnusco is going Ruby van Rook
okay one we can actually wait maybe four
for the handshake there you know I think
the Among Us unable
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
practical Viewpoint just go look a fade
here and
and unless maybe Rook C4 check is strong
maybe this is what he didn't like ah
okay and if King E34 G4 G8 though I
don't know this looks messy
maybe a forward but but you have to
calculate maybe a four actually does
work I don't know
oh so maybe they were maybe there were
just concrete reasons not to play Rooker
fade and then it's a lot more
understandable so this is a draw this
was also a draw between uh Robert and
Parham and Fabi uh beats good cash
sending or cash all the way down to -3
after six rounds and yeah I think we'll
take a bit of a break here and uh come
back to the conclusion of the round
Anish meanwhile has drawn against
haragafi yeah nobody nobody actually
plays Guinea four here so we have to
assume this is one of those fabled
incorrect placings of the king
which
uh
result in the notation being somewhat
spoiled
and interestingly Levon just blitzes out
Queen into here just is not interested
in anything else just wants to go for
active counter play
I wonder if Queen takes C7 F no F3 Rook
A1 you probably don't want to
entertain those ideas because you no
longer have your
immediate counter play so pretty sure
this idea is is just to take only five
and
start giving checks
yeah or maybe Queenie one check Queen E4
check first uh something along these
lines
[Music]
um
yeah yeah you can uh you can definitely
do that and ask the question although
honestly I mean it looks like it's kind
of permanently pinned on F3 but it's
also not quite clear how you're going to
be exploiting it there's ideas of uh
um
even possibly oh yeah whoa yeah that is
very very cute
anyway uh thanks uh thanks for staying
with us we'll
uh take a bit of a stretch and be back
with hopefully the the not very
prolonged final segment because it does
seem like I don't want to jinx ourselves
but it does seem that today's end games
might not actually last a hundred moves
they both seem manageable we'll see
we'll find out soon enough thanks
everybody for watching we'll be back in
a bit
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I know it's wrong but I don't care
[Music]
the fire is strong but I don't care
all I ever wanna be is
[Music]
where rise
[Music]
potato
ES
[Music]
the damage is done
but I don't care
[Music]
I don't care
[Music]
[Music]
save yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
about it later
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I know it's wrong but I don't care
thank you
[Music]
the fire is strong but I don't care
please
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
safe yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
probably the final segment of today's
show and we have plenty of results
uh
plenty of finished games let's put it
like this uh with only one game still
running I somehow felt there will be
more blood in today's round but so far
only one decisive result uh in a very
uh
I want to say strange game that Fabi won
against against good cash because it's
sort of uncharacteristic for this
generation of youngsters
to be so kind of utterly lost by move 15
in their repertoire openings I don't
think you see this very often they are
generally extremely well booked up and
also very tactically aware
which is a combination which generally
lends itself to not having losing
positions out of the opening but today
something
went badly badly wrong for good question
in a ragozin and uh perhaps we could
yeah let's start with this since we are
seemingly doing a bit of a recap uh this
is a honestly one of the topical and
perhaps one of the more ambitious
weirdly speaking
uh lines of the ragozin because of
uh it's tendency not to give Black
Forest draws
I think these days uh very often when
you say ambitious about a line
it actually sort of means exactly the
opposite of what it used to mean yeah
you're not aiming to refute the opening
you're aiming to get a playable position
and not let your opponent just equalize
by force by repeating home prep just to
keep things going as soon as possible
yeah and uh obviously there is a lot of
different ways of playing this position
I think rookie 8 remains maybe the main
line here
preparing additional squares for this
bishop and just often you you see this
weird interplay where
there is this competition who blinks
first and black doesn't want to play DC
and allow white or taken one tempo and
C4 and white doesn't want to play hp2
Bishop D3 so that you take two Tempe to
take on C4 so black plays A6 white plays
H3 and so on all kinds of really weird
stuff could arguably happen in these
types of positions it's even Knight A5
rather than 97 there's a whole bunch of
options for black yeah but yeah but 97
was clearly good guess's choice for the
day it wasn't like he wasn't forced to
do that it was obviously done
voluntarily
and then as David
very correctly pointed out this is also
very similar uh to the game that Lucas
himself
uh well eventually lost but should have
won
against the game which you could I think
make a solid argument decided the
outcome of the Olympian in Chennai uh uh
last year because had had good yashwan
uh India would have been NJB would have
been leading
uh the Olympia with one round to go and
probably all the tie breaks
um being quite favorable for them uh
they still would have had to play a very
strong team nothing would have been set
in stone but it would have been
obviously a much better situation for
them uh but speaking of today all of
this was played reasonably quickly C5
dc5 Rook C5 was also played reasonably
quickly and after Queen B2
you can make a solid argument black is
lost yeah
and this is just so unusual when you
watch games by uh by this generation of
of talent they don't do this stuff too
much yeah especially if you're playing
this line with whites uh he would have
been familiar with the ideas to be lost
six moves after or five moves after
playing 97 is yeah very surprising it's
happened a few times we should say in
this tournament the younger players
trying to Freestyle a bit and
um maybe you're not working out I
remember Jordan yesterday kind of
blitzed down a line and he was dead lost
a couple of moves after it left Theory
and there have been other examples but
yeah good cash I think it's just poor
form and he needs to study the ship
somehow it's never easy of course black
against Fabi anyone could lose this one
easily but just the style he'll be
disappointed it was very one-sided yeah
it's it's not it's not really the result
it's it's exactly as you're saying uh
losing sort of without really getting to
play a game of chess is always a very
annoying feeling and he will feel
somewhat like that because you know he
did he did finally Force Fabi to make a
couple of precise moves round of 20 in a
position which is
more or less completely busted your upon
down yet when your king is not safe and
there is no counter play and uh yeah
eventually if I did have to show some
technique but
giving a player of his caliber this much
of a head start
is never great yeah and in the meantime
uh when we were going on break there
were still two games running
now there's only one uh the game between
uh jingler and levenarian finished in a
drop the one played Queenie two and
after Queen takes C7 he did not
entertain this idea of Rook to xc5 which
I suspect holds but if there isn't if
there is a much simpler draw here there
is no reason yeah that's a very clever
move I've got to say rotate C5 Peter
Queen d8 check apparently stopping
stopping just from D1 to cover D1 and
now and then we run yeah and we actually
escape the gameplay
yeah but let's find a much cleaner
solution he just gave a check from
Yvonne as David was suggesting a check
from E4 and after King H2 you simply
play quinnitsu
and uh
there's no way white plays for a win if
he gives up on F2 I mean at least there
will be perpetual and you might play
yourself into trouble if you do that so
doing very understandably just repeated
here and the game was drawn
so the only game running is uh listening
between Wesley and
uh Vincent
which the bar tells us is completely
winning for white but you have to wonder
just how obvious it is and already
because
as we as we were going on break I
started calculating I think we left it
somewhere here and Vincent played Knight
B6
and
I realized that if you do it kind of
naively here let's say you play
uh for G4 maybe yeah let's take any four
can you six or four and black plays 95
check 995 I assume you want to play
Bishop D2 and black plays a five check
yeah
and you have to start wondering if this
is still winning or not
but Wesley has sidestepped at least this
streak because he played G4 instead of
f4 making it much harder for black to
blockade
anything uh on the king side
Knight A4 was the choice you still have
to ask
uh like after Knight G5 where does the
bishop go and
if it goes in the same direction Bishop
A1 just uh he's done it in the game so
maybe here as well yeah
um to try and win this night ah and all
that yeah all the one hang on if
five I think I can just yeah you can
take C3
and this never holds right this network
even if seven is probably winning
yeah even if seven is quite quite easily
winning the six check just king of three
and then which takes you three yep and
uh because this is the right color uh
the corner is
of the proper color for our Bishop we
are not really very worried about
converting this it shouldn't be very
difficult
um now day four chosen display one
so like if you don't play C4 you will
die uh not even very slowly like a four
or five H5 happens in position collapses
so you have to try C4 at least yes
um so what's the solution
a 405 King G3 is one way
for what sorry F4 Knight C5 no r95 is 95
is a very serious question King E3 it
should still be under control
um but we what's the threat now
uh let's say we go 93 question
Black's night will struggle to wait
though so if I play Bishop C3 yeah
Knights can never lose Tempi
uh we can have a pass it feels like now
I can play King
right okay
no Bishop D2 Knight F2 you're suddenly
coming behind yeah I mean even this
might be winning but I think in general
you would much rather not played 45 if
you can help it right you don't want to
do that to your structure even if you
suspect it's still enough yeah mostly
very quickly goes Bishop D4
T3 blitzed out
yeah we should be able to solve this now
I guess we just go
King G3 King E5 H5 probably
okay I'm also interested about F4 just
to try and uh
stop any calculation F4 sorry I'm in
Topic in D5 I can Define that position
options
we are also very fair
just because Black Knight doesn't have
too many moves C2 it should be three
yeah I can't even really get the king to
E4 properly right because we we have to
start by making a night move and then
the Knight gets attacked so let's say
might be talking [ __ ] two Knight C4 King
G3
might be too
but this is winning like King Jitsu King
E4 H5 takes takes king of five which six
King H6 yeah like this is winning
there might even have been a clever way
to force through the pawn with the left
five gf5 and uh I think we actually
Queen the pawn here because this is a
kind of a well-known setup where the
Knight can't cross anywhere and the
e-born just becomes a becomes a queen
straight away but I have a feeling H5 is
also not a mistake here uh because I
think after H5 the Knight just doesn't
return
I think the point is ghgh if you play C2
I will just take I'm pretty sure this is
a queen
yes because this is not great for giving
checks
then I can never get back to you yeah
and yeah if you have to play King E6
here I mean Bishop takes C3 is I mean
also just kicks you to team B3 is going
to be winning also H6 is a queen what am
I talking about everything is winning
here everything's yeah it feels like H5
is just a very very
uh clean way to more or less end the
game here like I don't see H5 played
yeah yeah it feels like this game is the
game is ending because the H1 just wins
now we'll see a handshake any second hmm
uh yeah simply a good game by Wesley
we've got to say but Vincent there was a
critical moment he let things go and in
this difficult end game he yeah this
might be one idea I think it was that's
that's the final
um
kind of slip final mistake oh no it was
earlier yeah it was here I wonder how
much time he had at this point
uh because
it is more 33 and if he went very very
low on time at this point it's maybe
justifiable but it's it is such a yeah
and there there you have it it looks
like there
uh signing the score sheets
uh so yeah Vincent also uh loses a
couple in a row he lost this very very
long game to live on yesterday
and lose another one uh today
but when the tournament isn't really
going your way particularly two blacks
in a row against uh livon and Wesley is
probably not what you want out of life
and
um just further restating the obvious
this is a very very
strong field
and he starting and playing well and it
is extremely important I can attest to
that as somebody who has never managed
to do any of those things you really
want to be doing well in it otherwise
problems sort of start piling up
yeah it's it's windy it's cold you don't
want to be struggling with these long
difficult losses but uh yeah they'll
both bounce back Vincent rukesh players
like that they're both strong enough and
still eight rounds to go but uh yeah it
was a nice technique from Wesley as well
yeah Wesley uh
he
arguably he didn't really get very much
out of the opening uh it was a very
peculiar kind of phone perhap because uh
Vincent went for uh the position after
B5 very very confidently I think this
was very clearly uh all home-cooked and
it looked risky like it at no point did
it look like it was a safe equality but
it did seem like he was equalizing and
then uh roundabout somewhere here he had
clearer Solutions
and he probably missed the fact that uh
specifically after all g8h4 Queen C8
which is a move you generally would like
to make without thinking uh runs into E6
and then problems are quite significant
but he recovered really well I thought
yeah he realized he maybe made a bit of
a mistake he settled down to uh to
calculate played correctly play G6 Queen
C8 Queen G8 giving up on H6 but creating
this counter play on The Queen side
and go to a position which I think he
would have saved
if not for that strange bit of
miscalculation we've produced the idea
to play 91 here
now the correct idea being very simply
taking and then starting to uh break up
the white structure or on the king side
and the main line I think very simply
goes uh takes takes and in this position
you just go King F7 and the activity on
the outside passer provide you with
enough counter play to
not have to worry too much yeah there's
a little material remaining issue
um should be enough to hold yeah and
this generally like you can you can just
do this on uh Common Sense grounds
and I'm pretty sure he very seriously
considers it because it is I think the
most natural option ab3 does look normal
and after 92 you realize you you have to
play quickly you have to generate
counter play or white will play a four
and we'll bring the king all the way to
G3 and only then take on B3 so F6 looks
very logical and
uh honestly assessing assessing some
position like this
uh shouldn't normally be a bit too much
of an issue for a player of his caliber
but
I'm feeling he overthought it I think
I'm pretty sure he got here realized
it's playable and then continued looking
for better and somehow tricked himself
into thinking that this works out
tactically it's a very cute idea because
Magna 3 has no squares
and he is trying basically to play B3
Bish by five C3
using the fact that metal G3 has no
squares
uh but giving white an additional
outside faster on the a file just turns
out to be on doing here
yeah especially against Knights that
white Pawn runs so quickly and uh yeah
in the other games lots of draws yeah
lots of draws some of them very hard for
some of them less so
um an open Spanish between Noida Beck
the leader of the tournament and
uh Prague was somewhat uneventful there
were some interesting complications uh
around the middle of the game but in the
end it devolved
uh into this position which I think we
both correctly called as very likely
just to draw despite White having a
healthy extra Pawn on E5 so that was uh
held a quirk is Sicilian between Richard
Rapport and Parham Maxwell didn't really
feel like it ever left
of equilibrium
and the I think the hardest part of all
the draws today was the game between
Geary and Arjun eragacy in which
Anish at some point was much better it's
hard to pinpoint exactly where things
went wrong uh I think the engine as I
mentioned uh without talking too much
about the opening which was a very very
sharp
uh Maron which I think Arjun misplayed a
little bit
but once we got to this type of
situation where black has
sort of decent control in the same time
but a very vulnerable King for the rest
of the game pretty much even if it gets
to A8 it Still Remains kind of on
vulnerable
uh it was very difficult to play
precisely but
I think somewhere around here the engine
was giving uh uh an issue
significant advantage
how do you feel uh Peter about Anish
bringing Jan as a second to my kanze
uh seems to be pissing off is this uh
I think it's common knowledge I saw some
tweets uh okay uh on chess 24. I was
slightly taken aback but okay I mean
it's it's obviously you know it's a
Development I've I've
heard rumors
for for a while and the first time this
was suggested to me as something that
could happen I was rather taken aback to
be honest
but I'm not surprised it's working well
I think you know I I rate Gusty very
highly as
as a theoretician and also as a human
being which I think is very important I
think
whenever some kind of a this kind of a
creative partnership is being formed uh
getting along with the person you're
working with is
I think a tremendous part of the
equation yes probably the most important
part yeah and I I think they are on very
good terms as far as I can tell and you
know the fact that both of them have a
lot of opening ideas is really not that
shocking
um
yeah and he's poaching some of the
some of the former
Magnus much Preppers is of course an
interesting story in and of itself but
uh yeah I guess if you can't join the
chicken chess club you might as well uh
hire one or two of them too to work for
you so yeah
you know perhaps that way you can get
nominated for chicken of the week
slightly less but I don't know if that
works we'll see about that yeah yeah no
guarantees I'm pretty sure that that was
not part of the contract Gusty would
never sign away such an important
such an important part of their
podcasting career a co-part of his week
yeah
yeah so still a very exciting round even
though at a certain point it definitely
looked like we might have more than just
two decisive games
um maybe we can check in on the
challenges uh the progress some of the
results sure have come in there yeah in
the challenges I guess the saddest
result of the day I mean there are two
kind of sad results of the day for me uh
one being the one we already covered
where Elena Roberts today got frankly
somewhat out class I think for the first
time in this tournament really yeah uh
the the the golf in uh enraging and
experience showed and she was soundly
beaten by Alexander Duncan on the white
side of a of a Cairo and there's also a
very sad game that uh jurgis lost to to
vaishali where he was pressing for the
entire game and then uh eventually why
Charlie seems to have equalized and this
is a position of move forward
uh and I don't know if he played King C5
just to make sure he doesn't lose on
time or if he actually made that move
with time on the clock and being fully
aware that this is more 41 and he can
think but regardless both King A4 and
King takes A5 are completely fine for
white instead he played King C5 and just
resigned not waiting for Knight takes D6
creating a throttle B5 check Bishop D6
Rook C8 checking B5 King takes D6 and
this is it might seem strange to resign
here but really it's a completely and
utterly lost King Rook ending with
coming into C2 and the King coming to G5
and the white king
completely out of the game on A5 it is
completely and
very very lost
yeah and it's it's a quaternary tale I
guess a lot of people talk about the
curse of move 41 this is pretty much a
classic example just yeah you should
never Blitz never rush just sit on your
hands calculate and splash some water on
your face you know take a break and you
can see five it's
maybe he just completely missed the idea
of Knight takes D6 until it was too late
but yeah it's uh it's really
heartbreaking it shows that tilt is real
and to resigned to resign without
waiting for Knight takes D6 for me
that's uh almost as unforgivable as king
C5
I would have thought okay black has a
bunch of sensible moves uh rugby four is
tempting Knight B6 is tempting I don't
know there might be some others would be
too at least wait for your opponent to
show you uh the win yeah I don't
disagree but the tournament is going so
poorly for him that I think this is by
this point it influencing his decision
making very very heavily and it's it's
very sad to see because I think he's a
very exciting player he continues
fighting he continues showing up and
sort of not
not just showing up to show up but like
trying every game is quite clear that at
least until today his Spirit wasn't
really broken and he was he was doing it
sort of in the right in the right way
but when everything seems to go against
you at some point it really does start
to uh to influence the way you're
playing uh in other results there was a
very fighting draw there between uh
Lewis Palace should be and uh jaheer
sundarov in the final position uh black
is a full exchange up but this king is
so much safer than this King and not
only three is such a powerful piece that
the the extra exchange doesn't really
get very keenly failed
uh and uh
Irvin was winning very beautifully early
on I wonder if he's still winning looks
like he is still winning but the game is
still ongoing which is something I did
not expect
uh but I assume I'm thinking she too you
still win because this probably drops
off eventually
hang on king3 sorry 93 I guess we just
go like G3 and then you take everything
slowly
uh and some games are still ongoing uh
there is
tricky end game between evich and ajiban
ajiban improve his position tremendously
somewhere like we saw this for the first
time straight out of the opening and it
looked like really the game will not
last very long very much longer because
the position looks like it's in complete
ruins
but adibon defended very very uh
tenaciously and now has I think genuine
drawing Chances with only one Pawn
uh left on the board you
I think you feel like maybe you should
be making a draw here even yeah there's
a few things a few things black can aim
for right you can if you get rid of that
pawn you can aim for rook and Knight
versus Rook sometimes because that pawn
promotes on a light Square you can just
somehow get rid of the Knights of the
Rooks and you'll draw it's hard to get
rid of the knights perhaps but in
general it's just hard to see what
White's plan is to make progress yeah
like I've got everything covered
absolutely and uh with the victory uh
over uh Elena Roberts uh we now have two
players in the lead mustafael and
Alexander Khan four and a half out of
six uh shindarov is on 4 and he will be
joined or overtaken by Vladimir ivich if
ivich actually still wins this game he
also joins
uh the two leaders if he draws
uh he will be tied for second with Joe
here Sandara and there is a
um I mean there is one clear person who
is not having a good tournament uh uh
jagrat she's on half a point out of six
having an absolute mayor uh everybody
else is very tightly bunched together
there's the vaishalis with minus two
having won that game against him she's a
minus two having not having a great
tournament but having a kind of an
understandable tournament she is
are raising Underdog in this field
yeah so Peter what do you think should
we uh stick with some of the challenges
games is it time to no I think I think
for today considering that the the the
the live game still going on are this
end game and also the
I assume very dry end game in in
Irving's game I I feel very okay uh
abandoning this for for the day and we
will update our viewers tomorrow uh
about how this ended but yeah does feel
like it's a it's a logical place to for
us to to wrap up and restart afresh or
you know as a fresh as we can manage
tomorrow from uh to PM central European
yeah
just one final trick uh oh actually
let's not point that out I wouldn't let
me against Maxwell madame Bishop F3 has
been played and yeah yeah I think we'll
be okay right you go although I was
gonna say just don't take on A4 on the
last half but uh yeah yeah yeah
this this has to be winning right it
will it will take much longer than I
expected but this has to be winning
it's actually a bit trickier than I
thought like Knight E3 now
yeah some pawns to drop off that F7 Pawn
is gone hmm
some work to do but he should uh I think
he should eventually get there yeah this
could have been this could have been
cleaner
this definitely could have been cleaner
anyway thanks everybody for watching we
will be uh we will be back tomorrow with
the continuation of this uh very
exciting couple of tournaments both the
Masters and Challengers shaping up
really really well uh but for today
thanks everybody and
goodbye see you tomorrow the definitive
solution for studying chess choose from
one of the largest online chess
libraries in the world with hundreds of
titles ranging from classic books
through to our exclusive chessable
courses
welcome everybody my name is former
World chess champion our starting a new
course here for chessable a very special
chessful course master your chest with
Judith bulgar you know what I learned a
lot
[Music]
she uh played the Berlin
which I service expected but I didn't
really know what to do against
because in reality very few people do
when we are playing an even game against
someone of similar strength to us
usually we need to give something in
order to obtain in shipping just how
shrewd and hunting alireza can be even
with very little time I want to show you
again just to prove that I play these
lines I played against former world
number two and
Superstar gattacamski
[Music]